[Music]
I
a
[Music]
[Applause]
mus
[Music]
a
mus
[Music]
B
d
[Applause]
[Music]
now
oh
[Music]
a
[Applause]
[Music]
mus
a
[Music]
mus
B
[Music]
[Applause]
now
you've seen the speed Chess
Championship now it's time for the rest
of us to get a turn with no Grand
Masters allowed it's the I'm not a GM
speed Chess Championship watch your
favorite chess personalities duke it out
in chess.com exciting speed chess
format there will be brilliancies GL
stacking another pop Bishop C3 and Rook
a one oh Rook a one there will be
blunders no no he fell for it see old
rivalries this is how I'm new
foes with a $15,000 prize pool who will
take home the crown this year he's up 80
and he SS Paulina Shala she moves on to
the final the IMC starts right
[Music]
now welcome for the final time to the I
am not a GM speechs Championship I'm
Robert hes alongside me is Kasa Corley
and we have the call for what should be
a great final between Gotham chess Levy
Rosman and Paulina shivala casa what are
you expecting today how pumped are you
I'm so excited folks get your seats
buckled it's going to be a really
exciting match with two folks who really
had incredible Journeys to get to this
point to the finals so really excited to
see these two compete today there was
hardly anything easy about it as you
said they took very tough Journeys here
to the final we started in the group
stage there were four groups of four
players only one Advanced through and we
see in the the top right Levy Rosman his
name was on top of Group B and Paulina
shalva on top of Group C she made it
through thanks to a tiebreaker against
Danny wrench whereas Levy he kind of
sailed through that group with only one
close match Picasa the semis they were a
different story yeah totally different
story We had both matches actually go to
the tie break and poina in particular
was extremely clutched because she
actually needed a win in her last bullet
game just to get to the tie break and
she did that and then she you know put
in more work clocked in overtime in the
final games of the tiebreak against
lawen Trent so really really
well-deserved levy on the flip side also
had a bit of drama and he was able to
write the ship in the tiebreak as well
so these folks are used to drama and I
think we might get more of that today
you call it drama Levy calls it content
he of course is the YouTube King of
Chess and Kasa when it comes down to the
story line here Levy he's more focused
on content Paulina she's more active
over the board who do you think is
favored going in yeah it really is the
that the ultimate question and I'm I'm
going to kind of dance around a little
bit but I'll say this paulina's been in
incredible form essentially all over the
board you know has an incredible in
credible run this year and I think she
just has you know she's probably a
slight a better chess player at this
point in general but Levy has been
experienced online for quite some time
and he's been quite effective and so I
think it's going to be a tug OFW between
you know who's kind of more in their
element more in their
bag yeah you say experience online I
think that is synonymous with the name
Gotham chess of course he is the biggest
chess content creator on YouTube and as
we look into the tape here he is in his
fourth IMC it's his second finals
appearance and overall throughout those
four im's cost a plus 55 woo he is
really steamrolling some of his
opposition yeah no question about it and
we should also mention and you could see
it on the screen here that he beat fuia
in last week's title Tuesday so and you
know revving up for this match you know
and revving up for the IMC he's actually
been playing pretty well and is in a
really good form and we saw it in the
previous matches as well so uh I think
he's going to be at home and ready to
really put up a good fight in this one
he'll need to carry that form into
today's match because back in 2021 just
two years ago Levy found himself in the
final but unfortunately he faced defeat
against Roberto Molina 12 and half 7 and
half Kasa history does not want to
repeat itself if you're a levy Rosman
fan yeah one of the really peculiar
things about that graphic there um was
that actually uh Levy lost the bullet
portion and in this year Year's edition
of the IM SEC he's actually been in
incredible in the bullet P segment so I
actually suspect that that if that was a
weakness before it's no longer a
weakness or liability it's an asset this
time around well Roberto was over 2800
in bullet Levy back then over 2700 So
it's not going to be easy for him he
knows that but it also means quite a lot
in fact he said as much after beating
Greg chih just the other
day I don't think I've played Pina at
all so uh I'm I'm excited to see like
where the openings go where the
preparation goes and uh hopefully my
second time in the final in this event
which has only happened four times uh
can go differently because then I will
qualify it's like getting your yellow
belt in Taekwondo you know you you don't
need to do the white belt stuff anymore
uh that that that'll be a big moment for
me I might you know hang it on the wall
behind
me he has a black belt opponent in front
of him in Paulin shivala so Kasa all
that talk about promoting getting to the
next belt he is in the finals and he's
facing the highest rated classical chess
player in the field yeah and someone who
again has been a really really good
player it's particularly improving this
year um she's yeah the highest rated
player in the field very close to 2500
essentially um and also has you know
came in fifth place in the Fay World Cup
this year so just kind cruising in in in
various uh disciplines and I think
Levy's going to have you know an
advantage in probably the quicker time
controls but shuvalova is going to
probably be a slight favorite in those
longer
controls we've seen her success in the
longest of time controls this year she
played in the World Cup she was
eliminated in The quarterfinals by
nurgul salamova who went on to finish in
a very surprising and impressive second
place so for Paulina she's shown that
she can hang with some of the best
players on the planet she lost in tie
breaks to salamova and here we see her
on the screen in front of us she's
always playing in the darkness Kasa but
she's always ready yeah and she also has
her game face on all the time I think
I've seen maybe one or two like Small
Smiles when she knows she's done done a
great thing but she usually has this
really focused posture throughout and um
you know you love to see that these
competitors really want it and I think
you know again sometimes you think a
it's you know who does this really
matter at the end of the day and yeah
the bragging rights matter the prize
money that's on the line matters and uh
these folks want to win yeah they really
do care and for poina she's more active
over the board that's a storyline that
we will keep repeating but sometimes
that actually can hurt you in newer
formats because this is not a format
that she is accustomed to different time
control three of them in fact and when
Paulina beat Lawrence Trent in the
postmatch interview she was talking
about some of her struggles where she's
not quite familiar with the 5 plus one
the starting point of this match so Casa
it's funny how being very active can
actually maybe hurt you in some ways
yeah and I think it's kind of
counterintuitive for folks to truly
appreciate this but a lot of times 3+
one has been this kind of the standard
fair that a lot of folks play in online
particularly with title Tuesday and so
every other time control that are
usually a little less familiarity and
you tend to see folks being playing too
slow in 5+ one and counterintuitively
too fast in one plus one and I think uh
you know making that adjustment and kind
of getting used to the increment there
and managing your time really well is
going to be a key for both players
Paulina she was very honest about this
and we witnessed it firsthand that she
was slower in those long time controls
against Lawrence Trent and we see the
players on screen these will be our two
contestants throughout the match tonight
and Levy Pina they deserve to be here
but they are going to have a long match
indeed because these matches they span
several hours and they also span three
different time patrols we start with 75
minutes of 5 minute base time with 1
second added per move we then get into
50 minutes of 3 minute plus 1 second
increment last and certainly not least
is 25 minutes of bullet chest
Kasa one minute to start not a lot of
time but that 1 second increment is
always super important oh it's critical
and I want to make a note here that the
5+ one is the only segment where there
will actually be a break during the
segment so the 3+ one and the and the
one plus one there's going to be no
breaks throughout and so there's no kind
of you know taking a little break when
you're you know basically tilted people
are going to have to adjust to the terms
and conditions during the match and
that's going to be really interesting to
see who adjust who switches openings who
makes faces when things aren't going
well because you know things can change
very quickly you use the words terms and
conditions part of the terms and
conditions of watching this show is
getting involved in chat so chat what do
you think will it be Levy better know as
Gotham chess or will it be Paulina
taking the title in this match let us
know your thoughts we may even feature
some of your chats but right now the
players they are getting set we see levy
on screen Casa he looks both bored but
also ready for a long battle yeah and
you know I think both both players here
are going to be kind of locked in and
and essentially thinking about right now
what am I going to play and on that note
I should mention both of these players
are experienced kocan uh players and so
I'm actually wondering on some level if
this might become a kocan Invitational
at some point um because we've seen in
previous matches Paia going for the
exchange with white sometimes Levy
playing it with black so I'm really
curious to see how many kerans will get
in this match and I'd set the over
runder at
10 okay you're getting into the X's and
O's the opening battles we heard Levy
talk about preparation and he said
specifically that the openings will be
interesting in this matchup and here we
go we are getting underway and we see
Levy and Paulina on screen will we get a
kacan in our very first game that's a
question that will be answered shortly
but I see them grabbing their mouse that
means we have
off and here we go we have something
totally different a queen's gamut
declined thus far and uh yeah now maybe
even turning into some terrorist like
Vibes the C5 move Robert yes we could
get an isolated Queen Pawn that's often
why white plays the structure is that
once we have an exchange of Pawns D5
could be a Target but look at Paulina
Levy started with C4 maybe she was
expecting that completely because she
has not spent any time at all
yeah and one of the things about this
structure that's important to note is
white is essentially playing against an
isolated Pawn on D5 black uh to
compensate for that has a little bit
more space in the center and he's and
basically he's going to want to keep
pieces on the board so Pina being black
she is going to want to uh keep piece on
the board and get some initiative
against White's King but E4 is an
interesting early tricky break and I'm
trying to figure it out because there is
a bishop in line with this queen on D1
but the only thing you can capture would
be this Knight on C6 and when this
bishop slides out the way the queen
defends his Bishop so poina says you're
going to sacrifice a pawn against me I
will gladly take it because as we noted
Knight takes Bishop takes the queen
protects that Bishop Kasa do you believe
in this Pawn sacrifice I think Levy is a
player that likes to play with the
initiative and I think there is some
compensation connected to playing Queen
A4 or queen C2 after capturing on C6 the
pawns on the queen side are split and
Pawn ons that are you know kind of I can
are split kind of isolated can become
targets and I think that's the the sort
of the nebulous compensation that Levy
is basically aiming for well actually
your queen a for wins back the pawn
immediately so this not is not going to
be a material deficit but considering
how much time Levy is spending I don't
think this was truly a sacrifice that he
was intending completely because he is
burning clock and maybe there will be
Queen C7 at some point hitting this H2
Pawn uh but Bishop G5 says not so fast
if you move your queen off the diagonal
I'm going to shatter your Pawn structure
over here on the king side yeah this is
already a really tricky uh you know
position basically for pina to navigate
because essentially if you do play that
Queen C7 you're going to double the the
F pawns and I think Bishop E7 is a bit
of a concession you're essentially you
know making sure your Pawn structure is
intact you're also punting on the E4
pawn and um I still think it's maybe
about equal I think the best that white
can hope for is basically having the the
the two on two on the queen side but
having the slightly better structure and
I think that's what Levy is going to aim
for in a few moves maybe maybe a move
like Queen C2 now makes sense or uh or
playing Queen takes d8 essentially the
point is you're going to take on F6 and
you're going to take on e4 but you don't
want the B2 Pawn to be hanging at the
end of that because the bishop will come
to F6 and and look at the B2 Pawn it's a
good point by you there because some
players would say I can immediately win
that Central Pawn that's a good thing to
do not so fast the beat tpon will be
hanging at the end of the line so Levy
he's doing the right thing by taking his
time Paulina was the one who we quoted
as saying I struggle in the five plus
one in managing my clock she's done very
well thus far so I don't see a real
issue for black just yet I like how you
point out split pawns on the queen side
that's a long-term Plus for white but
Levy needs to make sure he gets that
pawn back otherwise he will definitely
not be the one trying to get an
advantage yeah and pawns just for folks
that are out there you know you really
look for Pawn islands and to determine
who has the better structure not right
now black it kind of has three basically
the point is the E4 Pawn could be
connected to the F Pawn at some point so
that might be one Island and C6 and A7
are their own Islands so it's kind of
like a three to2 Dynamic here but of
course black is temporarily uh up a pawn
so that's that's kind of what it
accounts for in a way so but um but yeah
I think Knight Knight takes E4 or queen
C2 again is kind of the way to go I
think Queen C2 is a little bit more
natural though he decides to take on e4
I guess Bishop takes B2 will be met by
Knight D6 check and the black king will
not find shelter but Kasa taking a step
back from the X's and O's for a second
Levy he's playing this perfectly well we
see the eval Bar says that white maybe
has a tiny little plus but how about his
time consumption what does that tell you
this far or is it just game one and he's
getting warmed up I think Levy is
freestyling a little bit this is not
something he prepared at all but the one
thing I will say and a thing I really do
admire about Levy especially from his
previous matches is he definitely sticks
to his style and his style is to play
Dynamic uncompromising chess and so he's
inviting Paulina to grab pawns to keep
the king in the center and she wisely uh
declines this offer but I think that's
kind of what he's going for moves that
are tricky that keep chances for an
attack and so on I think Paulina should
be slightly favored in the technical
phases um but I think if if Levy plays
dynamically I think that's where his
chances really lock
and he does have the superior endgame
after the queen trade now look at Pina
she doesn't immediately recapture
because if she takes with her Rook then
Knight takes F6 G takes F6 you have bad
pawns all across the board that's not
the end of the world in a rook end game
she can also take back with the bishop
that way her kingside Pawn structure is
not compromised basa that actually
disconnects the Rooks that can give
white time to play Rook C1 Rook D1 I
would certainly take Levy's position in
the end game yeah no question about it
and you know Levy is actually going for
a technical position and kind of putting
Pina to the test to see how well she can
handle such a such a position I'd say
here that you know these Rook end games
are so notoriously drawn sometimes if
even even if they're pawned down so I'd
be quite Keen to connect my Rooks and
maintain the connection of my Rooks and
recapture with the F Rook um I
recognized that I'd spoil my structure
but I'm less concerned about that um but
Pina thinks otherwise it was just a
stylistic choice at this stage where
both positions will have a slight
Advantage for white she isn't just
focused on keeping the pawns equal by
material she wants to have a healthier
Pawn structure and some activity of her
own so she lashes out with F5 this
bishop could park on B6 at the right
moment and if you're not careful this F2
Pawn could be a long-term weakness that
Levy has to deal with so right now his
position is good and the big question is
does he leap forward with his Knight or
step backwards Knight to C5 for example
looks good but it shuts off the rook's
pressure on C6 Knight D6 you may be a
bit too loose over there a rook F6 idea
comes to mind so Levy now I'm starting
to get worried about his clock yeah he
is ticking down uh but I do think he
there's a degree of safety with it in
this position so if he really senses
serious danger he'll be able to probably
uh trade trade the miners or trade a
pair of Rooks Rook C2 is a really Savvy
move essentially covering the second
rank stopping infiltration with Rook E2
and I'm starting to like white if white
gets a few more consolidating moves you
see something like Rook D1 B3 G3 by the
way to give your king an escape Square
you always give your king an escape
score on the Square opposite of your
opponent's Bishop so given that there's
a dark Bishop you want to give your king
the Escape Square on G2 and that's why
G3 would be ideal you see a lot of
people automatically playing H3 and it's
really important to check what color
your opponent's Bishop is such an
instructive Point by you and look at how
Paulina is playing this is instructive
she says you want my six6 bond have it I
am going to activate my Rook on these
open files so go for that pawn Levy says
not so fast I'm going to play B3 first
just safeguarding a pawn that was
threatened by a bishop and now the
question for poine is can she make use
of her lead on the clock because Kasa I
look at 43 seconds for white that does
make me a little bit nervous even though
I understand White's position is super
stable right now yeah the only thing
about that isn't stable is again white
still has these back rank problems and
again B3 is a useful move but for me the
order of operations is always to deal
with the King first and let decides to
do it with another way with King F1
which also has a multi-purpose idea of
covering the E2 Square in the case that
uh the white Rook has to do some some
job elsewhere so I like how Levy is
handling this we don't love the time
management but uh I think he will start
to speed up here and wow Bishop D4 given
a question mark Knight D3 the right
reply from Levy I would be scared about
my knight being a bit loose here there's
a rook staring at it Bishop E3 comes to
mind because if you take my Bishop I
take your knight and then we both will
lose pawns C6 and E3 will leave the
board so this is a big moment for
Paulina but the advantage is in Levy's
favor I must say the way that Levy is
handling this this stuff thus far I
don't know if it's a Magnus game or what
because the positional maneuvering the
the slight structural Advantage the
tickling of the queen side uh weakness
here especially that C6 Pawn um really
really Savvy thus far and there's a
tactical justification if the bishop
does go to three be E3 as you described
this Knight will go to B4 and hit the
Rook on D5 and I think it's going to
happen
anyway and so she realized that those
trades would favor white and that's
something we should note that trades do
favor the side with the healthier Pawn
structure now this is just going to be a
free Pawn so what is paulina's plan at
this stage she is down a Pawn on the
queen side she's throwing her pawns
forward on the king side I think she's
trying to use time as a savior but Kasa
this does look just very nice for white
with great winning chances yeah
excellent weighing chances and you know
A4 is being was was given an X just
because it allowed A5 um you could have
start with B4 and then go on A4 and sto
this A5 advance so that was the point is
it's going to be hard for white to push
through the majority but these moves are
coming really really hot and heavy here
and basically Pina is trying to expand
on the the king side and keep white a
little distracted note the G3 finally
was played G3 King G2 so the king is
safe and sound but maybe black will
throw pawns forwards Rook e for is a
great move to play in your opponent's
Time Field watch out for F4 and H4
doesn't threaten Checkmate but it makes
White's life a little bit more difficult
and if this Rook can slide into D3
suddenly we'll have pressure and Rook D2
by the way the F2 that long-term
weakness that's very dangerous that
pressure on F2 is there and the problem
is if you go back with Rook C2 black
will actually double on the second rank
so forfeiting the second rank was a bit
of a controversial decision and I think
now there's a tactical opportunity yes
because the Knight is loose you can't
take the second rank Rook down goes F2
and you see it's
over3 G5 G4 now the king is in a box the
king is absolutely checkmated uh the
only Escape Square will be G5 for this
King so the black king may even step up
G oh Bishop Bishop d8 oh and Rook takes
H2 mate
wow what a turn around in game one as
Paulina Shu valiva takes it Kasa time
trouble was LE rosman's worst nightmare
yeah that was that was a bit of a
disaster and I think we also must give
Pina some credit there because she did
defend uh a position objectively where
she had some problems pretty actively so
that was impressive and here we go the
over under on kroons we got our first
one this is uh kocan number one in
exchange variation I think Levy actually
handled these positions pretty well and
uh we'll see how he handles it now H3
Bishop D7 is a very very unique unque
and interesting way to handle this
Robert yeah when you study the kacan and
Levy has cretic courses on it there are
many different ways where you even lose
a Tempo by bringing your Bishop back
like this but the base of the position
is solid I tend to like these positions
from the white side because I often say
the side that controls the pawn braks is
the side with the advantage this E5 Pawn
break is really difficult to orchestrate
so white has she put her pieces in the
center all on very natural squares and
there is no E5 for you B Arrow first one
of the day because all of White's pieces
are aimed at this square and I would say
that now for white how do you deal with
this Queens side Kasa I don't actually
have an easy answer to that because I
don't know where those pieces belong
yeah this queen was never going to
remain on B3 and queen C2 makes sense it
very much resembles a Carl's Bad
structure and for folks that you know
are curious about what that is you can
get it from a few different openings you
can get it from uh from a kacan exchange
like we're seeing it now you can get it
from a London system and essentially one
one side has a queenside pawn majority
one side has a kingside pawn majority in
this case white has the Queens Side Pawn
majority and essentially it's kind of
counterintuitive both sides tend to
advance on the side they start to they
essentially push their pawns on the side
where they have the minority where they
have less pawns to kind of shake the
tree or the base of the structure so for
black as uh Robert is basically pointing
out right now would love to attack the
base on B2 and C3 white in many
positions would love to attack uh the
base of Black's chain on the king side
sometimes playing H4 H5 H6 or sometimes
getting it F7 um and so that's typically
where the Contours of the game tend to
go and one way to take note of this for
yourselves at home is that players tend
to attack in the direction of their Pawn
chains Black's Pawn chain is going
towards the queen side White's Pawn
chain is going towards the center so we
look at these Pawn chains that's the
side that you typically play on and it
is counterintuitive as you said Kasa
because black is actually up a Pawn on
the king side and now speaking of that
extra Pawn in the center of the board
it's starting to look very promising for
black but I will have one caveat the
long term will be dangerous for black
because when you make committal Pawn
pushes you leave squares behind oh my
gosh so this is exactly the way that you
should conduct this initiative the way
Levy's handling it he's playing to his
style he's playing aggressively F5
entrenching that E4 Knight it's
basically like an OCT po night it it has
so many different avenues that that it's
looking at and it's really a dangerous
dangerous piece that being said longterm
the E5 square and even the F4 Square
those dark squares are weak I
affectionately call those types of uh
collar complexes swiss cheese because at
some point those holes might be occupied
to great effect um for white so in the
short term dangerous Initiative for
black in the long term white might have
a little something to work with but when
you say Swiss cheese might be some
people's favorite type of cheese they
might go for this now thinking that it's
uh going to be delicious but I think
what you're getting at is that there
just holes in the enemy camp and E5 and
F4 will be available Bishop A4 tickled
that Rook don't play B3 and make your
Pawn loose so Kasa the engine says it's
about level both sides have chances here
would you prefer to have white or black
right now honestly I'd prefer to have
white right now because the burden is
with on black to kind of justify this F5
move and the longer the game goes
without an attack crashing through the
more problematic that move will seem but
it's a matter of style and Levy's style
generally speaking is to play a bit more
aggressively so it's entirely
Justified and one big issue for black is
you can't push pawns backwards white is
just about ready to boot that Knight out
of E4 and once that Knight gets out the
way watch out down the E Line the E6
Pawn is an eyesore it's a backwards Pawn
so here's a critical moment for Levy as
he is going to think do I take this
Knight on E5 that gives up the pair of
Bishops or do I say my knight on the rim
is dim let's bring it back towards the
center yeah at the end of that line if
you play Bishop takes E5 D takes E5
Queen takes E5 the A7 Pawn is hanging
and also that Queen might be uh with the
Knight nestled on e4 might be in a bit
of a pin so there might be some F3
possibilities later so I actually don't
think taking the pawn E5 is actually
feasible right now don't go for it
unless you're sacrificing a piece that
would be very interesting Levy instead
plays A6 so the good news is his Pawn is
no longer hanging the bad news is he
gives up more dark squares to the player
who has the only dark Square Bishop on
the board this Knight is kick back I
would not be going to G5 I think that
invites me to kick your knight back once
more and just get a clamp on the king
side I'd be going to C5 putting pressure
on the flight score Bishop yeah yeah
makes a lot of sense here and the one
thing I will say about Levy's play in
this game just a little bit different is
he started out really aggressive and I
love that and then he started to make
these moves on the queen side like
Knight A5 Bishop A4 I think it
distracted from the King side attack and
what basically the purpose of F5 was
doing and so to me it's it's really
important to play on the side that
you're better and I would have contended
like five six moves ago black was
definitely better on the king side and
that was where he should have directed
his
attention and now the kingside is closed
that's actually good news for black
because the bishop on B1 might deliver a
checkmating attack if not for this Pawn
on F5 this Pawn back on F7 you'd have
problems Bishop D4 given that
exclamation point I think it was a
pretty natural move for pina her Bishop
was threatened by a knight let me go to
a square that defends my Pawn which is
under attack twice and Kasa what I'm
seeing in the future G4 is coming to a
theater near you and I'm just blasting
open the king side that Bishop that I
said is not happy with the pawn F5 let's
get that pawn out the way and go for
checkmate ooh G4 is a move G4 is
definitely a move I would I would
definitely want to get some more pieces
to the party before opening the position
like that but I like what you're
thinking and the point is again Black's
Black's Focus now is on firmly on the
queen side these Knights on C4 C5 as a
matter of fact look at that Cal
cavalcade a piece on the C file you
don't see that every day if you put a
bishop on C6 it would hang the Knight on
C5 but that'd be a lot of pieces lined
up um and yeah White's focus is uh is
over over y on the king side so um
really interesting to see how this plays
out paulina's time management as well
has been pretty good so she was you know
saying I don't I don't know what I'm
doing with this 5 plus one I think she
knows what she's doing now she's got
some matches under her belt well perfect
can be the enemy of the good so
sometimes it is better to play good
moves quickly rather than the perfect
move slowly so she brings her King to H1
Levy goes Queen E7 G4 now might be met
by some kind of queen H4 the white king
will be in some Danger so she might have
to slow play this a bit she is up by
nearly 30 seconds on the clock but the
plans are not easy to come by yeah but I
think you just got to make some natural
moves uh Queen F2 is a good one covering
the H4 Square I think you just got to
move some piece and see how it h see how
it happens um this KN on F1 maybe could
be improved um maybe a move like Knight
Knight E3 perhaps or you know I you know
what I really want that Knight I want
that Knight on F4 but you you're three
squares away horizontally or vertically
it's so difficult to get a knight there
it usually takes three moves to do so um
and uh yeah it's it's just if I could
just you know pick it up and put it
somewhere else that would be fantastic
but alas I gotta I gotta wait well I
don't have to wait I can hold it here
forever so I have the mouse I can
control that but it's a really
instructive point from Kasa that this
Knight is not playing its part in what
could be an attack and now Pina is down
to just about a minute she's lower on
the clock against Levy that's really
good new news for him as he tries to get
his first victory yeah folks move move
move these pieces you you got have you
guys have are don't have that much time
you got to make natural you just got to
make some moves the game is going to be
decided later and you notice this in
classical chess all the time too where
you know you want to think a long time
when you see a new move or a novelty or
something like that and instead you
realize the game's not going to be
decided right now anyway it's better to
bank on that time later and I think Pina
is not adjusting to this she has to move
she's under 30 seconds I'm shocked that
she's spending this much time I mean she
now plays Knight to E3 that's a move she
could have played in 1 second in a
bullet game and been happy with Levy
Retreats quickly it doesn't have to be
the best move it was approved by the
engine but he is making moves quickly
and now Pina down to 20 seconds how is
she burning so much clock yeah no again
it's just it's just not it's not
adjusting to the new situation and you
can see here after B takes C4 Levy is
has a new Avenue on the B beline
whenever he wants and so uh be careful
with this n on C5 this n C5 is about to
be a dominant piece it can potentially
go to E4 or D3 at the right moment um
and so yeah the two Bishops here are not
really showing themselves the way they
typically do and 11 black doesn't really
even wow G5 I was about to say Black's
Bishop not playing so G5 played to open
up the king side and Rook E3 I like a
good Rook lip but look at black getting
to the g- file just in time yeah and
again Levy STS to be a aggressive when
he's playing aggressively that's usually
the best version of himself and so I'm
loving the G5 move especially playing
against her four seconds I can't believe
how low she has got on a clock but right
now is a big question for Levy what is
White's plan to trying to figure out and
this Knight on C5 if it ever goes to
those light squares of course it's going
to be captured and the black king does
need to be careful at the end of the day
if that dial can open up it will be a
Checkmate yeah and it's a really weird
position because oh I I don't love uh G
takes F4 because now that dark Square
Bishop has a future and that H6 Pawn is
a little loose um who who's it easier to
play right now the side that has more
time so I still think Levy has an easier
go of it right now but look at her pre
moving she's I'm a queen it's over she
could not find the accurate moves in her
time trouble credit to Levy Rosman
finding all of the best choices there
winning the game evening this match up
that was all about the clock the
position was even for a little while
Pina maybe was slightly better Levy had
a a few moments and then basically if
this match comes down to time scrambles
I like levy on in most instances so I
think she really uh Pina that is has to
be a little bit savier about managing
her clock she was Her Own Worst Enemy
there was no reason she had to spend
that much time the position was not
tactically sharp at that moment and if
she had conserved some of that time she
would have better chances in that
scramble but look here we are in game
three we have a trpovski from Levy black
strikes early with C5 challenging for
the center and you see that we have a
capture so the tension is removed and we
have kind of like a kocan so Kasa does
this count in your uh counter for a
number of times we had the caracon I
want it to because it's we're basically
in the same Carl's Bad s structure from
exchange kocan again but um if I was a
if I was a bookie you know this would uh
if I was one of these uh these casinos
in Vegas I don't think I'd be able to to
count it so I'm going to I'm going to
say no even though it technically is
it's a transposition and that happens in
chess you can sometimes start with one
opening and then transpose into another
so this resembles an exchange kacan if
the pawn went to E4 and took on D5 and
black C Pawn took back so A6 played your
light Square Bishop wants to get out to
B5 that's no longer available I tend to
like these positions long term from the
white side but but there's something a
bit strange to me about this bishop on
H4 Casa like why is it over here if
you're not going to take on F6 then what
is your Bishop doing yeah that's a
that's a question and you know the same
could be said to White's light squared
Bishop because a lot of times in these
Carl's Bad structures the dream Square
for that Bishop is the is the square D3
because you're pointing toward the king
side but Pina beat the bishop to the
diagonal the bishop on F5 got there
first and that normally doesn't happen
and so both of White's Bishops are a
little suspect right now and it's for
that reason that you see the bar ever so
slightly in Black's favor just because
addressing that is going to be bit of an
issue now question for the folks at home
and and for you as well Robert if that
Bishop was to take the Knight on F6 how
would black
recapture well it's a question we might
have to answer in a future game because
now the Knight is up on e4 but probably
the G Pawn capturing towards the center
is usually what we advise and opening up
a g file against where the white king
might go but Kasa that's maybe a future
game problem right now I think white has
many other issues Pawn on E5
overextended F3 play to kick the bishop
back so Ben fold is unhappy but the
bishop on F1 is at least a bit relieved
and no longer has to defend this G2 Pawn
Yeah and again you you said it this
long-term it's not just the diagonal
towards the king this G1 A7 diagonal
this this F2 Square that's soft it's
also the entire second rank so if the
king ever castles uh King side
um and even queenside with the pawn on
C3 the the same Dynamic exists um it's
just extremely Airy it's like leaving
the back door open at night you know you
don't want any strangers or Intruders
getting into your house right like we
don't want that we want to sleep
securely and when you push this FPA and
you're not able to just sleep
securely yeah but sometimes if you're
inviting your friends over you just
leave the back door open so they know
how to come in where you don't have to
get out of your chair every single time
so sometimes just there for a party I
cannot believe you Castle Queen side I I
kind of was just making a joke for a
second and then I see the king is on C1
I feel like you're asking for trouble by
being on this side of the board you're
maybe a pawn down on the queen side basa
B5 that comes to mind Rook C8 this Rook
can also slam on the C4 Square white has
no space no control and a more
vulnerable King yeah the funny thing
about it is the middle games and the end
games now favor Black they the end games
favor Black because I was going to say
before this bishop E7 move all of black
White's Pawns are on dark squares and
they don't complement the the dark squar
Bishop very well whereas black that's
kind of the Opposites the case most of
the pawns are on light squares and they
really complement the bishop on E7
really well and so I thought the end
games are pretty favorable the middle
games are favorable because the King on
C1 is a little vulnerable and
theoretically there there should be a
little bit of a faster initiative on
that half open file with Rook C8 and B5
although Levy is changing that I mean
he's basically hinting at G5 or H5 at
some point if black castles and you know
you have to demonstrate some Bravery
here to Castle right now I I mean I
think I'd probably play Rook C8 and
delay castling for a little while and B5
essentially does the same thing B5 is a
really good move as you said delays
castling this Rook is tied down to the
pawn if and when black Castle's Kings
side we may see G5 blasting open that
side the board using the H6 Pawn as a
hook Levy going forward here Rook C8
Rook C4 you mentioned second rank issues
there going to be some fourth rank issu
and that's why Levy tries to clog the
fourth rank before the black BR gets
there and she plays it anyway yeah and I
think here there's a little bit of an
oversight here that after Rook takes C4
you can actually uh conveniently capture
with the B Pawn because there's some
Queen A4 check and queen B8 check
Dynamics so you have to take with a D-
pawn and that actually I think means
that the worst is over for white as far
as the king safety is concerned because
then there isn't a clear open file on
the b or the C file for Black's heavy
pieces the the remaining Queen and Rook
to operate on so I think Rook C4 is a
little imprecise but still black is not
in any real danger yeah I'm with you
there definitely an imprecise move I
think she rushed it she still has 3
minutes and 20 seconds on her clock
there was no need to play that decision
so quickly but that happens when you
feel like you have no danger in your
current setup and now she's paused so
she did pre-move Dake C4 maybe she
wasn't expecting Rook takes C4 she does
of course capture this way I still would
prefer black position Kasa because after
Castle The Rook The Rook is stuck on H1
because H4 is loose yeah and it's funny
because you really want to open the H5
with a move like G5 but it'll be like
ships passing in the night if G5 is
played Black will play H5 and they'll be
no levers essentially towards that black
king I still like pina's position and
you know what's more important than her
position it's the situation with the
clock as as long as she remains healthy
up on the clock that's ultimately going
to determine these games or the time
scrambles and again Levy is pretty
vicious in these time scrambles so you
don't want to give him that
chance but Pina is a very technical
player so when you give her an
opportunity to seize control of certain
squares and she can also go for an
attack I was just thinking the end game
but we have a queen and Rook on the
board for each side G5 doesn't look
threatening B4 on the other hand go a B4
Queen takes C4 I know I'm giving up a
pawn there might be a queen B7 Rook C8
and before you know but this King on C
one's in grave danger that is dirty and
Pina spots it she senses those tactics
there are there's a little bit of
trouble in Paradise here this King on C1
is not on uh not on a secure Square they
might have to go a do a little bit of
tour to France somewhere but the problem
is where is he going to
hide I can't get to G3 quickly enough I
think I'll get check muted before I get
that far this looks terrible for what I
actually don't see easy defensive moves
Rook G three apparently that's a huge
mistake because B takes C3 I know that
you want to take with this Rook but even
when you take with the Rook the H4 Pawn
is hanging that one that you push
earlier going for the attack it's loose
and I think all of White's King side
collapses yeah that is a that is a
tricky Nuance to spot I would have
played Rook d8 myself and just put the
Rook on the half open file because or
not half open the completely open file
and just make the King on C1 rethink its
life decisions um Queen C5 is also a
very legit move Levy needs a queen trade
expeditiously like I mean if the Queen
stay on the board another 5 to 10 moves
I think it's just going to be
over especially with the clock situation
Queen E3 I am not trading but Levy might
Follow The Queen back and forth if he
can the problem is Queen C6 Queen F3
Queen A4 and I get away same idea with
Queen A5 I'm escaping Queen trades and
if you put King B1 to defend A2 this
black Rook can join the party this Pawn
can push to B3 wow he takes on B4 it's a
good decision because if Queen takes A2
there's actually Queen A3 which forces
the Queens off the board and that's
exactly what Levy needs the other funny
thing is we talk we spoke about split
Pawns in the first game of the match we
have the same Dynamic the issue is King
safety if the Queens are off the board
white would be advantaged here because
the split pawns it's those queens and
again F5 ignores TR forgets about trying
to trade queens and now I think Pina
should have something on the on the
queen side particularly with this King
Stone
C1 and she play C3 which not only goes
after the king and opens files when you
lose pawns you open files exclamation
point deserve G4 is loose so Levy's King
side will likely Fall Apart he doesn't
have enough pieces to deliver checkmates
oasa he has to find a move he's about to
hit 10 seconds I do not like this
position one bit for white yeah this
queen is just about to go big game
hunting um I see Pac-Man Vibes in the
future here just you know get the Rook
on d8 into the game and the rest should
take care of itself I don't know whether
you throw in a check first maybe you
throw like a queen F4 or a queen G1 and
then bring the rook in but that
basically uh is is the way to handle
this yeah Rook d8 one of those moves
where you think oh I can take this Pawn
in front of the king or Rook G3 but with
a rook coming to d8 there will be mating
threats she first with Queen G1 check
and then Rook d8 maybe just trying to
caion Rook
d36 yeah Queen G6 now pin that Rook how
do we feel about those Pawn end games
though Robert there is a two versus one
for white on the queen side so I don't
think you can trade everything because
then all of a sudden it's Levy's pawns
that will get home faster although isn't
this some kind of not zuk's wrong but at
some point White's not going to be able
to move if I play Queen E4 what are
white I guess you do have King D2 so you
actually will be able to escape a bit
you are right about the outside pass
Pawn for white but black has an extra
Pawn in the center another thing to
point out is this Pawn of G7 is going to
be an umbrella for a little while it's
basically not a pawn that needs to be
captured right away there are improving
moves that can be made instead H5
maybe even A5 I would have loved to play
A5 before though because uh before I am
a little bit worried about oh she takes
the pawn okay never disre disregard all
of what was
discussed well I was trying to find an
umbrella I think we need that for a
glyph but now she is going after all the
pawns so can't she just start taking
them like if you take this Pawn on E5 A6
does drop and then it becomes a bit of a
pawn race you do not want to just go
Pawn Gra take all them and allow your
opponent to Queen play A5 first don't
even allow excellent practical move
don't allow the capture of the a pawn
keep everything relatively symmetrical
every Queen trade now loses cuz uh
pina's up a pawn so essentially you just
got to you know make a few Queen moves
and then eventually there's usually a
blunder in such scenarios um okay so you
said Queen trades win for black I like
Queen to B4 then if that Queen gets over
there I feel like black should be
winning the good news as well for pina
Queen C2 picks up A4 that's a second
pawn and that's a more important one and
there no and there no checks there
because the King was on G3 so now it's
just checking uh checking your way
towards the king this queen be Queen B2
will zigzag and yeah now all the pawns
are being captured and in fact Queen
takes H5 wait Queen G5 trade the quids
okay does it yeah and Levy resigns he
actually gets resignation off before his
flag Falls so it is 2 to one in
paulina's favor and Kasa Paulina has
been the faster player out of the gates
and so Levy he's struggling on the clock
in game two he was able to turn it
around in game three the clock was one
of the villains for him I like where
Levy's at though I think he understands
that he's got to you know basically play
a little bit more actively early on take
the initiative and and hopefully get her
thinking sooner Paulina knows the
opposite if she basically manages her
time well gets through these openings
relatively cleanly and she's up when the
time scrambles happen you she has to
like her chances and so that's kind of
the tug of war that's playing playing
out right now and we see a position that
sort of resembles a French to some
extent that Bishop on C8 is stuck at
home behind a pawn so that's not the
best piece in the world but that E5 Pawn
this has been a theme of the day is that
pawn a strength limiting the scope of
Black's pieces or is it a long-term
weakness that you can go after because
it to protect it you need to continue
overextending your position yeah it's
funny looking at this because again this
did come from a kocan so we're again in
the kocan invitation um going on over
here um but it's this line where the
bishop stays on C8 and it takes on the
character of a French now the reason
black is likes to play this or is
comfortable playing this is because you
have this pressure on the E5 Pawn in the
long term and that might become a Target
in the middle game in the and in the
short term white used that pawn as a
wedge to initiate attack so um you know
if the King was to Castle uh if this
King black king was to Castle there
already some great gift possibilities
with Bishop H7 and Knight G5 and again
you're probably going to see a similar
dynamic as we saw in a previous black
game where the king stays on E8 for a
little while it probably has to as you
mentioned the Greek gift sacrifice could
land a Checkmate in White's favor we saw
Gregory kaidanov do something similar to
Jordan v forest in thear Masters and C3
played here black hand Castle there is
no Greek gift just yet but even if you
do Castle White often plays H4 and says
take my Pawn Alpha zero style I'm
hunting your king yeah and I love the C3
move that white played because you
basically secure the bishop on the
diagonal with Bishop C2 Queen A4 I'm not
so sure if that you want to actually
take that A7 Pawn I don't know if it's
it's a risky Pawn kind of it's can you
even call it big game hunting it's
really small game hunting right The Rook
Pawn on A7 you're kind of disregarding
all all the other principles of chest
your Rooks aren't connected yet I feel
like that's probably not a pawn you need
to defend no but if you'd asked Paulina
a move move AG go where does your queen
belong when it's on D1 the answer is
probably G4 so she's actually trying to
use this as a decoy if Levy goes ahead
and defends that pawn which he does
Queen slides the G4 and suddenly the
black king is in some serious trouble
Robert prophetic that was prophetic
stuff um you know we we definitely need
to take you uh you ever play the lottery
um because uh those numbers you're giv
her pretty good um but yeah this is
exactly right to allow the queen to get
to G4 is not really great now your H4
business that you mentioned earlier
comes into play and I think black would
have to respond with a move like H5
giving full control of the dark squares
but look at Paulina she plays B3 because
maybe black had an idea to get some play
of his own she says no you are not going
to get active in this setup I don't see
moves for black right now you're
definitely not castling here kaso do you
have an idea not just a single move but
an idea for black at the stage yeah I'm
going to Turtle a little bit I'm going
to play Bishop to B7 I'm going to
probably play Rook C8 I'm going to
actually sometimes play C4 as a
sacrifice because after B takes C4 my
knight gets the C5 Square my Bishop that
might be on B7 opens up on a long
diagonal so you know all is not lost
here um but it was very important for
Levy to nudge this queen because Bishop
takes G6 sacrifices are possible uh with
the queen being on the on the G line
well now the queen is on the F line at
some point Knight G5 is going to be an
idea for pina just to secure the pair of
Bishops you can't allow a white to
Chisel at this F7 Pawn a pawn chain is
only as strong as its base pawn and this
F7 Pawn it's really the hero it may be
little but it's doing a lot of heavy
lifting defending Pawn chains in both
directions so because I'm looking at
this bishop B7 feels mandatory but I
just don't see the follow-up working I
know you mentioned C4 I'm playing H3 I'm
shutting down your Pawn pushes here and
I keep passing the turn back to you
until you show me what you have plan I'm
going to go again I'm going to I was
going to say Rook H5 it's always a nice
aesthetic when you push the H Pawn up
the board that your Rook can activate
that way and so Levy definitely likes uh
the artistic uh elements of Chess but
again Bishop Bishop to B7 um okay now we
got to defend G6 again hold on so again
the point is that I think if you give
black time to do some of these things
you can sort of Mount the C4 break
whether it's a sacrifice or not you get
some counterplay if se4 doesn't happen I
totally agree with you but I think
that's basically what uh what black has
to aim for is a is the C4 break cuz
that's the only break in the position
right and we said no Pawn break no
plan mhm I don't see an easy plan so
that might make sense for black I'm
looking at the clock as well Pino well
ahead on time and she's trying to come
up with a plan because her pieces look
perfectly placed but she doesn't have
that knockout just yet and so to improve
your pieces I would first play Bishop D2
which might also open up the idea of B4
to carve out the D 4 Square for this
Knight so there are many different
options in this position for white I
think they're playing on the queen side
at some point being bringing a rook to
B1 throwing your pawns up the board you
can create a passer as black sits on its
last rank doing not all that much in
terms of activity yeah it's such a good
observation Robert because if you just
look at the pieces that black can
actually move the n on f8 can't move
because the bishop takes G6 the bishop
on E7 can't move because there's no
Square where it doesn't hang the queen
on d8 can hardly move as well so entally
it's really hard for black to come up
with anything active and it allows Pina
the time to just kind of you know you
know basically take the temperature make
sure everything is aligned where she
likes it and that is really the problem
that Levy has an A3 points it out better
than probably any move we've seen thus
far fact you could literally line your
pawns modest modestly like that on the
third Rank and slowly prepare B4 perhaps
in the manner that you were describing
before with Bishop D2 is shocking but
also demonstrates how bad Black's
position is and these Rooks are not
connected so if files open up and there
are some trades there could be a
Checkmate on the last rank because the
Rook on H5 it's not contributing to the
defense of the king it is protecting H4
so it's needed on this flank and Rook C1
was paulina's Choice it's very clear
she's going for B4 like she made all of
her previous moves it's given a question
mark Kasa because B4 directly was
clearly better but the avenge is still
plus 1.7 so it's not like that was a too
big of a mistake yeah folks ignore the
the question mark here sometimes when
you make moves and they're and they're
all a part of a logical plan they're
it's actually really sensible and that's
basically the dynamic here um B4 is
still on the agenda she can even make a
few more uh you know prepatory moves and
she doesn't feel great about allowing C4
with Tempo but B4 now is excellent
timing perfect timing this bishop on C6
it does shield the queen from The Rook
oh and C4 so this move we were talking
about earlier in the game something
something that you could do but now all
of Black's pieces are shut out so she
moves a bishop to F1 which okay the
engine hates it because Kasa now the
Knight is free and now the E5 Pawn might
be free that black can steal yeah and
it's a bit surprising because now that
Bishop on F1 to be active again is going
to have to go somewhere else um but hold
on now the F the E Pawn can be probably
reinforced with Rook E1 or Bishop D4 or
something that essentially just protects
it that 97 move was critical because it
came with a really important Tempo um
yeah that that was a little bit of a
surprising sequence but uh this queen on
G4 also we should just point out the
queen on G4 is nicely placed but it also
couldn't move so I like this Knight on
D4 giving the queen some
air and I don't like Black's clock
Whit's mov seem easier to play at least
for Levy I was going to say he's solid
but now he gets active he wants to pin
this bishop if it steals the pawn and
quick shout out to nearly 25,000 of you
watching this match between your YouTube
hero Gotham chess and Paulina Shela who
is about 2500 fet a the highest rated
player in this competition and currently
with a 2-1 lead so Kasa a leading the
clock by nearly a minute for Paulina how
do you continue amping up the pressure I
think you try and get the Rook on B1 in
the game I I would probably consider a
move like rookie three and rookie one or
doubling you can also pressure the G5
Pawn uh Knight takes H4 as a threat here
folks The Rook on Jade is unprotected
and basically it's just hard for black
to make moves without blundering and
here we go that pawn is available um and
open for business and yeah now it's off
the board and it's getting late for her
and she might be hungry so she snacks on
the H4 Pawn but that's just the start
that Knight is going right back to F3
then Pawn to H4 this pin isn't really
going anywhere this feels like not just
a little Pawn on the flank but okay H4
now and I can't really look at this much
longer yeah my eyes but the point is
though is this has actually been really
really really well conducted and it's
partially because pina's just up on the
clock if she stays up on the clock good
things happen all right Bishop E3 or
just makes a lot of sense just hitting
that Queen kicking it off that diagonal
then maybe going for H5 which Again The
Rook on on G8 is still unprotected so H5
it okay trading also makes sense and
yeah okay paen as as a technical player
she's like I've had enough of these
pieces I greed is not needed um I'm
gonna you know head T that game and look
it Levy under 5 Seconds basically one
tactic here to watch out for this queen
pins the F2 Pawn so as long as she
doesn't play a move like Bishop H3 or
something like that maybe she moves her
King up to G2 she can also bring her
Knight up to G5 to close the G file
that's the one blunder to avoid right
now and she stops it yeah and again she
has 50 seconds so of course she can find
this because it's actually not going to
be hard for her to find good moves when
she's up this much on the clock and
again she's just making all all the
improvements she needs she's Ren making
all the
renovations and she has the time to do
it and she now wins on the spot with H6
The Rook will have to sacrifice for the
Knight and that shouldn't stop the
checkmating pattern Queen F6 attacks a
loose Knight and oh gosh H6 is going to
hurt can you sack your queen there is it
almost H6 Rook G6 and then
H7 uh sure why not that wins a queen Tak
F7 will be mate and one so I always like
to say Kasa when you see mate look for
better Fair very fair
and uh yeah H7 does it Queen F6 does it
um again I I think she might even trade
Queens here but she shouldn't she
shouldn't she goes H7 and now there's no
way to get to this Pawn so she should
bring her Rook to the G file and I think
that would end this game now I must say
I'm surprised that Levy's playing this
out given that you know there's a match
clock here but I think he's thinking
that this might be one of her best
segments so he's going to make maybe
play out these positions and uh even if
they're
lost right and she hasn't always o
please take my yeah that's just a nice
finesse and that is winning so Paulina
shova takes the first two-point lead of
this match she currently is up three to
one so Levy the break comes at a great
time for him you see him stretch while
Paulina stretched her lead to two
points my goodness there's just a lot
going on right now and stay tuned
because uh this match is just
just heated
up Levy Rosman still in his chair
probably looking over that game and he
has his work cut out for him because he
Trails by a score of 3 to one at the
moment so Kasa what does levy need to do
differently to catch up he's got to play
a little bit faster so that Paulina has
to make decisions Under Pressure she's
basically in her bag essentially having
a minute a minute and change in
positions where she just got to maneuver
and find one or two really nice moves
before ending the game so she's got to
make those decisions or have to make
those decisions with 20 30 seconds left
that'll give Levy a good
shot for sure so Levy he will need to
just take a step back revisit some of
the openings and he has plenty of life
left the match is long the players are
taking a break will do the same so
subscribers stay tuned during the break
as we take you inside a prestigious
chest Club in London where a former
British champion meets a young proy they
talk chess Improvement and put their
skill to the test we'll be right
[Music]
back
do you know about Nobel
prizes no over 50 members of the
Atheneum have won Nobel prizes bertran
Russell Winston Churchill rajer Kipling
have you heard of you're too young you
don't know all these
[Music]
people tactically I'm quite I'm still
quite strong I can still you give me a
position in the pay for white to play
and win the first move I think of is
usually the answer I think I'm quite
good at the ren games but I'm not sure
about my weakness this is the I think
the most expensive Bri library in the
world after British
museum this is the Darwin chair have you
heard of Charles Darwin he di on this
chair they play between each other chair
can I go up the stairs or am I not
allowed do you want to go up the stairs
I've never been up the stairs let's go
up the stairs
this is
high what's this thing over here it's an
old thing for parcel post so if you have
to send a parcel you weigh you put the
parcel in one and you put the weights in
the other and when it balances you know
the parcel weighs 4 or um so many
[Music]
grams I think the optimal age for
playing my best chest will probably be
when I'm somewhere around a teenager
mid-30s is probably the
the people reach their reach their
strongest and um so at age 79 I'm
probably a bit past
[Music]
it see that's
interesting
[Music]
sh
yeah yeah there're just in time thank
[Music]
you
w
[Music]
there's Gotham chess is he uploading
some content to YouTube no he's probably
just texting some friends and they
likely are rooting him on as he Trails
the match at the moment one point for
him three for Paulina shalva and Levy he
is extraordinarily wellknown
across the world he also just released
his book how to win a chess you see it
there behind him and he is YouTube's
largest chess Channel with 4 plus
million subscribers and 1.8 billion plus
total views the list goes on and on with
him it doesn't even dos service to read
this graphic basa right now none of that
matters he could be the best streamer in
the world of all time but he's still
trailing 3 to1 to Paulina Shala yeah and
I think the story thus far has been the
time management specific Al pina's done
a really great job of not allowing Levy
to show his prowess in these scrambles
and so the adjustment I would have Levy
make would be to play faster to at least
give Paulina some difficult decisions in
time trouble because I do believe he has
the edge uh if the position or the
status quo of the position is still
unclear heading into those time
scrambles thus far pina's been dominant
and and so at the end it's only been
making one or two accurate moves to
finish things off and so he's got to
keep the game in the balance for
longer that was nearly perfect execution
from Paulina in that last game right
before the break she wins with the white
pieces she had complete control over the
board whereas Levy's pieces they were
stuck in the mud so a great showing thus
far for pina I'm going to ask YouTube
chat a question I know many of you are
here supporting Gotham chess do you
think he has what it takes to come back
against someone like Paulina 20 500 Plus
in classical Fay rating Kasa we know how
strong she is but this is a better start
than maybe even she could have imagined
based on her level of play yeah no
question about it and I think we're
going to see a little bit of something
different here and here we go already we
have our a liftoff and we're in London
land we didn't see Bishop F4 we saw Trum
palski land before so oh and I stand
corrected now not traditional London
jobava London so totally different
approach already
perhaps Levy took a deep dive into D
nitz's opening repertoire along with
Alexander bortnik they released a course
on the jabal London look at this Pawn on
G4 and Paulina says no way you're not
going to catch me grabbing that one I'm
not opening this G file for you to go
after my King instead the Knight jumps
into E4 so Kasa I'm not super familiar
with the ins and outs of this opening
but the reason I like Knight E4 as it
welcome C5 it also might threaten to
move like G5 at some moment yeah I love
the red from the start from Levy you
don't take that pawn on G4 few moves
back because there's these Rook G1 ideas
nastily picking up the G7 pawn and just
getting a initiative on the G file and I
think essentially white is is a little
bit better because uh going to probably
connect their Rooks first um the the the
knight uh on C3 has now been captured
but even after recapture white just
needs two moves to connect their Rooks
you could see something like Queen F3
happening um you could you could even
you can even see something like A3
happening but I think ultimately white
has a little bit of an initiative here
and can even continue to push on the
king side well white would like to
Castle Queen side but the problem is
once this bishop captures then that
flank will be open so A3 is a really
good move because if black took on C3
then white cast King side now white has
the choice so A3 was played at the
correct time here you can take on D6
you're not very afraid of Bishop takes
F4 and pawn taks back I think that
actually could play into White's hands
yeah but the funny thing about Bishop D6
is that Pina is just trying to take the
fire extinguisher and douse it just go
and right now basically if she's able to
trade a few pieces that attack is going
to be blunted and then those pawns that
are have been pushed will be probably
overextended and not very impressive so
Levy's going to try and you know make
the magic happen by keeping some on the
board and Pina is going to be like you
want to trade you want to trade you want
to
trade and look at poina playing B5 she
said let's trade punches right now if
you want to Castle queenside and attack
me on uh this side of the board I'm
going to play B4 and open up where your
king will land so E4 played speaking of
opening up the center is about to be
ripped open and Kasa D takes E4 that
looks like a move that you just
immediately resign after because I just
don't like the look of the Rook sitting
in the corner oh no we want to live we
want to live and so we're going to make
decisions that Keep Us Alive and uh
taking on E on e4 was a bad idea Pina
develops instead plays Bishop B7 and Lev
is a decision here does he try and get a
little bit greedy and take on D5 does he
close the position and play E5 um does
he keep the tension that these are
really tough decisions to make uh
particularly in faster time controls
Robert because you could have a
situation where this this move here
decides the next
10 it does because after E5 blacks move
as force and then comes C5 that idea is
more or less Force he castles kingside
he keeps the tension both in the center
with the pawns and between the Bishops I
like that decision I think Caston Queens
side was too risky C kingside makes
perfect sense and Kasa you called it
White's Rooks connect first but
currently there are no open files so
what are those Rooks going to do yeah
and the other thing about castling King
side is that pawn on G4 will stick out
like a sore thumb uh the longer the game
goes that pawn was back on G3 it'd be a
very very clear advantage to White um
because white is all those other great
things we talked about Rooks being
connected Center control and so on paen
is going to try and trade some pieces
and then make that G4 Pawn look really
really bad so I wouldn't be surprised to
see an exchange on e4 or F4 right now
and I think she's trying to figure out
which one makes more sense and Levy
correctly predicted that Bishop takes F4
will be played that was pre moved by him
and now after Knight takes E4 I don't
think that black should go Pawn grabbing
in the center not when you haven't
connected your Rooks and your queen side
is UN developed Knight takes a E4 Queen
D4 I would even look at Rook D1 the C7
Pawn is loose it feels like you're
playing with fire so if I were uh Levy
here I would just take this Pawn on e4
and then ask those questions right
afterwards yeah and I'm actually curious
for folks that in the chat that actually
uh have pre moved before do you feel
like pre-move usually works out for you
or it doesn't like because I feel like
I'm not someone that really is so keen
on pre-moving until I'm down to my last
few seconds and it's like a Time
scramble otherwise I assume nothing but
okay Levy's preo was connected to uh a
recapture so you understand that but if
it's not a pre moved uh if it's not a
recapture I'm not pre-moving
squat I think the chat will say pre-move
what's that some of them and others
would be like no I never pre-move and
other like well I like playing games as
quickly as possible so let's get them
done with let's pre-move every single
turn and now the advantage is in Black's
favor Kasa at first glance this looks
really good for white but then you
remember that your Pawn is on G4 if that
pawn were on G3 or G2 we'd be telling a
very different story yeah it's the
combination of that with this
combination of just trading pieces and
again Pina is the really really good
technical player and she's saying the
more pieces I trade the less attack or
initiative you have against me and the
more that G4 Pawn sticks out like a sore
thumb and that's essentially what's
happening and so uh I don't like the way
this is trending for Levy but uh we
still have plenty of game left and I I
do think he is more attached on the time
than he has been in previous games on
the clock and so as long as he kind of
keeps the time kind of close uh I think
he'll have his chance D5 here might
actually be really sensible way to
activate some piece and at least try to
attack again and he goes for it and now
it's a big choice for Paulina who is
ahead on the clock does she trade
liquidate likely to a relatively even
position or play E5 and that means that
we can split the board in half she
chooses the trades she is up two points
in this match her Queen can slide to E7
I still would prefer black even if white
is first to the open file because King
safety is Paramount in quicker time
controls I just don't like the location
of this opponent on G4 yeah it it's
still it's still a bit annoying although
now that there aren't any Knights or
minor pieces on the board it's at least
a bit easier to manage that liability I
think Levy will probably go H3 and
protect that G4 pawn and then maybe even
bring the king up to G2 just to
consolidate things on the king side and
then you start to feel good about
White's you know control of the
file and Rook d8 says you're not going
to control that file forever Rook takes
D5 you would like to take with the queen
to increase control over that file and
she actually plays C5 I like that no
more backward Pawn we can push it all
the way up here I just feel like Paulina
is doing everything correctly and for
Levy he's done nothing wrong but the
position remains level yeah it is a very
very equalist position I think both
sides have a few more improving moves to
make Rook D3 is is is almost like a bit
of a waiting move but also invites this
idea of Rook E3 potentially and yeah
paulina's advancing making more
improving moves herself so very very
level it's going to be very curious to
see how who manages their time better in
the next minute or so and Levy down to
125 Pina has 145 so some extra time much
needed for her as Levy is super fast in
the scrambles and here is a big question
does Paulina play Rook d8 essentially is
saying I'm okay making a draw she says
no Rook E8 and Kasa this queen side for
white I feel like it could be vulnerable
if you're not looking closely there
could be a C3 shot to shatter that pawn
structure yeah it's funny because the
eval bar definitely didn't change after
that move but that's a move that conveys
ambition and I think part of that
ambition is based on the fact that
paulina's up about 40 seconds and so she
feels like I'm not in any time trouble
why do I need to be conservative I feel
like I'm the better player player um and
that's basically what that move says
King G3 is bold what I that is a move I
would not have predicted it's the last
game of the season going to hold nothing
back King to G3 this is a final worthy
move saying I am going to push my king
forward you have one simple check it
doesn't do much and queen E2 that's a
move that can really hurt you if you
trade black is already on the verge of
winning a pawn and if you don't trade
Kasa Queen F1 that looks scary with your
king up on G3 yeah the king G3 move is
puzzling Queen E2 makes a lot of Rook D7
is a really really smart move you
Counterattack on F7 not giving black the
time to you know get any aggressive
attacking ideas and I think the queen on
E2 should probably dart back to E6 I'm
not keen on trading Queens here because
then the king would have controlled the
E2 Square uh the entry Square for the
black Rook so just defend F7 and uh and
chill and that's what pina's doing and
again the time she's still up this needs
to change for Levy to to make inroads
and this Rook goes to A7 keeping the
queen honest also Rook A8 becomes an
option uh the pawn F7 is annoying for
black to deal with you would like to
make him move like King H7 to get off
the last Rank and here Levy may play the
move Rook to A8 I actually don't think
this is an immediate draw just because
you're trading off pieces I still feel
like black has a slight slight Edge just
because of this silly Pawn on G4 yeah no
question and if you had to pick what's
the most valuable Pawn on the board
right now it's probably the pawn on C4
that black pawn and so uh it's yeah it's
equal there's so many Perpetual checks
here that come into play G6 tries to
cover the diagonal although I I I'm I'm
skeptical that there'll be U many many
uh refurbish uh refurbishing moves here
for black to make um there there will
always be some perpetuals but one thing
queen of six can you actually trade
queens or does the black king get out
too quickly these are difficult
questions to answer you don't have much
time C3 if you want to play for win you
definitely play C3 here uh but for
Paulina she may say I'm still ah heading
the match I'll play a calm move like C
takes b i I feel like Levy is handling
this quite well and for Paulina her lead
on the clock it's shrinking yeah Queen
B2 is a very bold and aggressive move it
kind of forces White's hand I think
Lev's going to take on C4 and then we'll
see what's up here okay so Queen E4
looks right to me queen queen take C2
why giv why give up the C2 Pawn now the
C C4 Pawn remember we said this like 10
moves go is the most dangerous Pawn it's
three squares away from queening and
it's coming with Tempo Queen E2 check
don't push C3 or you hang your queen
nope so Queen E5 first now C3 is
available but Queen B2 actually putting
the queen on the other side of the pawn
was probably just winning on the spot
because the queen would have ushered the
pawn through but here this is also good
enough but look at this on E3 covering
the checking s Queen
D2 here comes the new Queen Paulina
shalva the lead on the clock is paying
dividends she now leads by three full
points Kasa it seems like she's an
entirely different player than we saw
her against Lawrence Trent yeah you
could see her class I mean that was as
equal position as equal gets and she was
able to outplay Levy because she's at 30
seconds and a lot of good moves to make
and I'm wondering Levy's now switching
the openings is this a little bit of
tilt or is this just uh trying to mix
things up because a scan Aven was not on
my bingo card it's a nod to the first
winner of the I am not GMM speed Chess
Championship John Bartholomew I know
you're either watching now you'll watch
at some point somebody will send you
this clip we wish you well he was the
first winner of the IMC he is a tried
and true Scandinavian player # team
scandy but this opening it's not seen
very often at the highest levels though
I love playing it in Blitz chess because
I actually think it's a tough nut to
crack it is it is a very annoying move
opening to play against particularly if
because you don't see it that often and
one of the things that I think even
justifies this opening for for black is
the Pawn on D4 feels isolated it's not
isolated but it sometimes feels that way
because the Knight on C3 is in the way
of the Pawn on C2 reinforcing it and and
for that reason that I think black can
can play this way although I must say
this bishop B4 business I haven't really
uh been very familiar with I've seen
this type of position before but I I I
have a bias towards the Bishops Robert
yeah though with a rook coming to d8
very quickly this Pawn D4 is a Target
Bishop G4 is coming soon as well and I
just feel like as you said the C Pawn
needs to be on C3 now D5 play K black
just he does he's speeding up and he's
playing better yeah I I love that
decision and actually I know I probably
isn't favored but as as as white here I
probably would consider actually just
sacking the queen at this point just
because I think other tries are just not
as desirable at least there'd be a bit
of an imbalance there and Black's King
King King side pawns would be split so I
actually would sack the queen here and
go for that position otherwise you're
just losing a clean pawn and Black's
pieces just look very good you need to
take your practical chances so even
though this is only a pawn I'm going to
put that in air quotes taking this way
giving up your queen for a rook in a
minor piece that would have given the
black king some difficult choices so
instead she was B4 I think this Knight
can just slink back to E7 to gather this
Pawn on D5 and black is is simply up
upon PA you have to love Levy's position
and look at the difference folks for the
first time in a while pina's the one a
minute down on the clock and that's the
game she lost when she lost a a Time
scramble where she was down and it's
starting to Trend that way and Bishop E4
a nice move instead of bring the Knight
back the bishop forward going after this
nice Pawn on D5 and so we're about to
see a position where black is simply a
pawn up but Kasa there is some some
danger here for example if Bishop takes
and we swap pieces this looks like the
best way to capture because your Pawn
structure doesn't get ruined uh anymore
if you take so you take with the E Pawn
you have double isolated pawns sorry
I'll fix my arrows here those pawns be
very weak but after those trade C4 would
happen fast and Levy says let me get
this Knight off the board he wants
Knight E5 Yeah so basically he wants to
get all the minor pieces off the board
and have a relatively no risk end game
where you have uh you know all the heavy
piece on the board and just a clean
extra Pawn I like the decision I think I
think it kind of uh it makes a lot of
sense um and uh it's going to be
unpleasant to even begin to try to
defend this because uh black will also
in addition to all those other
advantages probably have the open
file and she plays Queen F4 going after
this Pawn on F6 if I'm Levy I note that
I'm up a pawn this queen is about to
pester me I might bring my own Queen in
when you're up material trades are often
advisable so Queen D4 it also will get
the Queens off in a nice way for black
where you keep control over this open D
file the only open file I might add yeah
it's an excellent move I mean it's a
really really classy decision and I
would even consider Rook F5 now just
harassing the queen further reinforcing
the F6 Pawn a very natural move um and
played by Levy and um I'm liking his
decisions right now he's playing great
quicker uh with a clear purpose and his
opening choice to go to the SK na so far
it is paying off and with this queen on
F3 under threat from this Rook on F5 she
slides to G3 that does welcome a
doubling on the G file I think for black
the game will be closer to a victory
once you connect your Rooks in a
meaningful way yeah and I I think
allowing these tempos for The Rook to
activate are really really dangerous you
you pretty much have to go G3 here um
and that's what Pina does and now the
queen is just being harassed the one
argument I could say is white needed to
create an escape square and you
basically helped white do that that
being said you've activated both your
Rooks at Tempo I mean this Rook on A1 is
doing absolutely nothing and uh it's
going to be hard to find a real
breakthrough here that's the thing I I I
would have been again it's it's a bias
personally I would have been more
comfortable trading the Queens um
because I don't want to allow any
counterplay against my own king um and
now Pina is going to get some
activity uh oh ca you were just saying
it and now I'm really seeing it that if
Queen lines up with The Rook on the
defile that could be what the start of a
mating attack and also if you Queen G4 I
might play Queen to E3 because I'm
spying this A7 Pawn this is not easy for
black to deal with and he's backtracking
and his pieces are not coordinated
nicely yeah and Rook D5 runs into Queen
H7 the queen would actually infiltrate
uh on that square and start attacking
stuff and you can't nudge the king over
to B8 either because their back rank
mates uh connect Ed to sacking the queen
on d8 and so some issues here and it's
this is now tough to defend I think
Queen C6 just manages to keep everything
together and for Paulina she needs to
keep going forward she doesn't have B5
she plays Queen D4 going after this Pawn
King B8 would walk into that back ring
check you talked about and B6 at a
perfect moment for Levy his King now has
an Escape Route but the light squares
are going to be vulnerable long term for
this black king you know I I think Levy
made a few great decisions here I'm
going to say crisis averted at least the
short-term crisis because there were
some real back rank issues there Queen
C6 was really clever although this light
Square check Queen E4 why do you allow
that one now this Rook will come to D7
uhoh and that could definitely turn this
game around so you know it's been
interesting is that at first Levy played
Super quickly and he was able to obtain
Advantage then Paulina was the one
playing a bunch of quick moves and she
was able to cut in to Levy's advantage
and why is she thinking Rook D7 looks
Auto automatic maybe she's worried about
some kind of Pawn push at the right
moment but the queen on e4 does cover
that square the other point is black
again has back rank problems because
this queen is looking at the B7 Square
so all right Rook D3 was a passive way
of of essentially doing the same thing
the reason Rook D7 was a little bit
better is cu you get a Tempo on F7 but I
think she's eyeing these breakthroughs
on G3 the queen on C5 makes the F2 Pawn
pinned and so she's worried about some
Rook takes G3 tactics and is over
protecting that square she's also lining
up rook D1 because Queen takes F2 check
King H1 there is no check on this F3
Square thanks to this Rook on D3 so
she's lining up a Checkmate attack of
her own and I actually think that this
is a really big threat right now you're
sacrifice a pawn in front of your king
with check and yet it's the black king
that will get mated first vicious and
the time look at the time all of a
sudden pina's back in business up on the
clock and that is not where Levy wants
to be he's got to keep that momentum up
and Rook E5 is a good move yeah kicking
this Queen off of the diagonal if it
goes back to F3 while the C4 Pawn is
loose and that gives Rook D5 to Black in
the near future so some of these
decisions won't be particularly easy we
could see a repetition if the the queen
and the Rooks go from the F to the E
files but Paulina she might be thinking
about more here as it went from a bad
position to one where her King it kind
of does feel slightly safer wow Queen H7
is really aggressive um
C4 Now is really loose uh I guess you
defend it with Rook C1 no uh Pina is
like forget that I'm going to punt on my
queenside pawns and seek activity I
think just this should probably favor
Levy just because you know his Pawn
should theoretically be faster and it'll
be hard with the all the heavy piece on
the board to even entertain pushing the
white Kings Side Pawn so tricky position
but again Levy's back on top on the
clock and that's what he needed um Pina
is going to have to make some tough
decisions under duress and that's I
think all you can ask for it's a strange
imbalance and actually it's funny that
we see the features just a well balanced
game this one I don't see this position
as being balanced at least by the pawn
structure if B5 Falls which it may on
this turn and it just was captured F6
Falls white is actually up a Pawn on the
king side and black is up two pawns on
the queen side so that's how I like to
look at these positions these are two
extra pawns and this Pawn is an extra
one for white but neither side can push
those Pawns very easily because as soon
as you push Pawns in front of your king
and the King's to opposite flanks then
your king is susceptible to checks and
maybe to mat so Kasa how do you see this
game continuing yeah I think basically
black will probably start to shove the a
pawn just because it still preserves
your own shelter so I think A5 A4
something like that going up I think
conversely white might do the same thing
and make a move like H4 to just at least
you know sort of like you know it's like
gentlemen start your engines you know
just basically just getting the pawns
revved up for when the Queens ultimately
are exchanged and then you feel more
comfortable running them down the board
and A5 step one A4 please take me as
your Rook needs that Defender so the
queen slides to C5 and it also
threatened a rook F5 that's so The Rook
slid back to D2 I see the question mark
but I'm looking at the clock and that's
the best thing that Pina is going for
she's up over 10 seconds yeah and H4
again it makes a lot of sense although
tactically maybe it would have been
savier to give that Queen F3 check first
cuz now F2 is under tremendous fire and
where does that Queen even go there
aren't so many square shs G6 I like that
because she's keeping her eyes on the
light squares and E6 is hanging so if
you don't protect that pawn white is
going to steal it yeah but look at the
pressure on F2 here very very dangerous
Black's Rooks are attacking White's
Rooks are defending and queen E4 check
very nice move although Rook takes G3
was a threat of move ago do you TR
Queens yeah and then go like this with
with your Rooks yeah it makes a lot of
sense you can generate pressure on that
C7 Pawn with Tempo and if that pawn
comes off the board you start to feel
very good if you're white so yeah Queen
takes C6 is probably the logical Choice
here and she made her choice with five
seconds remaining on her clock reminder
everyone they get second added per move
ly down under 5 Seconds see an
idea folks this is going to be a
scramble they got to
move okay white is coordinated very
nicely Rook C1 comes to mind but then
Queen F3 for black at some point he
steals the
awn there's nothing hanging in uh in
Black's position everything is
covered oh nice Queen trade now from
Levy he didn't take F2 he says my pawns
are too fast way too fast and white is
doesn't can't even sniff a pass Pawn yet
and Rook A5 seals the deal that is an a
runner and that's that's a touchdown
basically that pawn is about to get to
A1 that is the way Le does it and again
the The Contours of the game there were
very clear if you are asking Pina
difficult questions under duress you got
to like Levy's chances he is I think the
favorite in those time scrambles if Pina
has a lot of time in her clock and she's
got to figure out how to navigate the
position she's going to do it and so
yeah that's the adjustment that he's got
to make and I think he's starting to
realize it well where are we at on the
kocon counter because I think this was
four all right we're at number four and
this H Pawn is not H4 it's going all the
way up the board this has become
thematic it's a very topical line and
even though you're pushing Pawns in
front of your king you have four pawns
to three on this flank over here so
black uses the extra Pawn on that side
of the board to her Advantage basa the
extra Pawn in the center that also tells
part of the story yeah and it's it's a
funny one because usually this H Pawn
can be entertained as a lever to kind of
get at uh White's kingside sometimes you
you throw an H3 and you make sure that
white has permanent back rank problems
but right now it's a bit a bit tepid and
I think in the long term some of these
piece trades can favor white because if
all the pieces get vacuumed off the
board and it's just a pure Pawn in game
white would actually be winning because
you can manufacture a pass Pawn in the
center with the four versus three and so
we're long ways from that and I would
reckon we're not going to get a pawn
endgame but that is in general uh one of
White's long-term
prospects that's completely true Levy
read his book during the break how to
win a chess it seems like that would
help him start winning some games but
Paulina maybe she writes the book on
some of this kakan Theory she induces
f33 which is a longterm weakness on
these dark squares and then Retreats the
bishop to E6 give me this control B5 in
the near future that's another typical
move you see in the Caro as I'm starting
to prefer blackith position and her
clock is part of the equation yeah F3
just leaves the back door open again I I
don't know about I just I don't like
strangers in my house at night and so
I'm not I'm keeping everything locked
and F3 is just a bit too inviting um
yeah it's again it's the diagonal to
that King and it's the second rank in
the long term just dangerous A5 we saw
this uh theme on previous game where
you're the side with has a pawn minority
and you're the one pushing it's really
to kind of undermine the chain and also
uh and also restrict you know the
activity of white so uh I'm not a huge
fan of the queen trade to be honest but
black is totally fine here and a lot of
it has to do with this expansion on the
queen side and also the fact that this
bishop on D3 has no active diagonals if
queens were on the board if I could
place a queen over on H5 I might go for
checkmate but this bishop will stare
into enemy pawns and that's not good
news at the moment for that piece and
I'm not sure Kasa but you might have to
take this bishop because if you push B4
down goes A2 I will gladly grab that
pawn and otherwise you're going to lose
a Pawn on the Square currently sits yeah
and I think essentially White's best
chance now is to get to some type of
double Rook end game where the minor
Pieces come off the board I could see a
scenario where there's like Knight takes
the bishop on E6 and then after Knight
takes E6 Bishop C4 and trying to
essentially Whittle some of the pieces
is down this H4 Pawn let's not forget
this is a thorn in white side because if
white ever plays G3 black will play H3
and that pawn will be cemented there and
so longterm here it's very annoying for
this King on G1 to find real you know
breathing room because it's hard to kind
of dart out and again the back door is
open so far I would say a perfectly
executed position in the kacan from the
black side pina's in everything right if
this Rook takes on E6 you UND double
your pawns you capture it towards the
center and then your king can run out to
F7 so black has the space the side that
controls the pawn breaks is usually the
side with the advantage and she rushed
King f8 I was thinking B5 first to boot
this bishop back and then give your
knight the D5 square but she doesn't
want to do anything committal so I can
hardly blame her for starting with King
to f8 yeah yeah I I definitely respect
King f8 because she just wants to take
away this rookie seven Invasion right
that was part of the concern was The
Rook getting to the seventh ring
and uh yeah because that didn't happen
um now you know she could still kind of
chisel away at the queenside pawns
there's maybe Knight B5 or Knight D5 is
a possibility that C3 Pawn is very soft
and again this H4 Pawn is very annoying
um and so you know white might actually
need to try find some way to get rid of
it and it's not convenient it might take
a few moves like G3 G4 and then King G3
something like that
so she goes Knight D5 welcoming an
exchange of of minor pieces after C
takes D5 how do you defend both of these
pawns I know white is essentially up a
Pawn on the queen side but after Rook A3
you have to use your rook in a passive
way and for black it might be time to
start bringing this King up and you
could push all of your pawns so a king
and Pawn in game that would likely be
even winning for white because of these
double pawns but with the Rooks on the
board I'm taking black yeah I'm worried
I'm worried for Levy because even though
the computer says this is equal this is
the type of thing where it's oneway
traffic in my estimation as this King
starts to move towards the the center
King E7 King D6 it's going to be really
hard to keep everything together
although Lev is doing the right thing
he's basically going to try and play
King C1 and then King B2 and free up The
Rook to get active on the E file but
this is so much easier to play for black
because white has several backward pawns
right the A2 Pawn is backward and the C3
Pawn is backward and so the majority uh
on the on the queen side's really a faux
majority it's a fake majority it can't
be mobilized well that's what happens
when two pawns take care of three and G3
played so there's some good news to that
this would just offer a trade of Pawns
and if we see a trade there the king
would run out but look at her executing
your plan Casa this is for the end of
the game if we keep the Rooks on the
board H2 will be a permanent long-term
weakness but if those Rooks come off
then H3 is the pawn that will staying on
that square and uhoh don't you now F5
might be a really good lever for the
king to actually all of a sudden Dart in
toward the kingside pawns again do not
ever let this Rook on A3 get to the
second rank because it will Nestle
itself on G2 and you'll have a very hard
hard time as white ever trying to trade
those Rooks uh because the pawn on H3
will become a g pawn and then Gary will
Queen F5 was a missed opportunity though
it was a missed opportunity now white
will have the opportunity
oh F5 again yeah this is F5 the problem
for white is that black has UND doubled
her pawns which means she has a
legitimate Pawn majority on the king
side and if her King is able to get into
a squel like E4 that's that so King F2
cover the square oh what an idea by Yuka
take away the GT Square then throw the
second Pawn forward and I don't think
that white can do anything to stop it
and the problem is this King on F2 on
the second rank is in a box so white can
never really get active like you might
say well how about Rook C2 to B2 and
then you capture on B5 well the problem
is is as soon as Black's Rook gets the
second rank I said this before if there
ever there's a rook takes A2 check this
Rook will Nestle itself on G2 and it
will be trouble in Paradise there'll be
no real active way to get rid of that
rook and so the question for black
really is how do you finish the game
because white is now going to have to
sit and black is going to have to figure
out how to improve what would where
would you go with it Robert she's doing
what I was about to suggest she might
bring her King right back over to G6 and
then play Pawn to F5 and then figure out
the rest later and Levy down under 20
seconds he has to go Rook C2 I don't
think he could have went Rook E5 as you
said Rook A2 with check if this Rook
gets to H1 the game is over and that's
why this Rook needs to stay on the
second rank yeah and again she has all
the time in the world in the world so
that's that's the issue here at some
point now you're going to have a
protected passer on on a four needs to
be babysat and this Rook on a A3 will
reposition itself uh to greener pastures
and it can just stay there maybe the
black king might walk forward to A5 and
B4 now I think you play B4 pawns Rook G3
oh my God oh my
goodness oh my goodness hide your kids
that that is you get two connected
passers two squares away from queening
The Rook cannot stop it this Rook A7 is
a much more tame approach and just as
effective but what you just suggested
was
spectacular I kind of you know I don't
root for any player but that would just
be a sight for sore eyes a rook landing
on G3 because if that capture happens
you have two passers that can't be
stopped and The Rook is coming in so
this might just happen oh my goodness
and she even can protect on C6 and Blake
King C6 that's how much time she has she
doesn't even have to be down material to
to win the game now and this is just
torturous I think the only reason this
is continuing is because it's the last
game of the segment and uh yeah we know
that you know Levy's probably more of a
favorite as the the time control
quickens but this has been tough now
wait Rook wait Rook F3 was an
opportunity Rook F3 could have picked
off the H Pawn bring The King The King
The King needs to move to A4 A3
comforable Rook G3 I'm telling you it
wins it Robert that is brilliant man
that is a brilliant move it is hard it's
hard for us folks to sometimes find that
man but yeah honestly even F3 wins now
because G G4 is hanging or you can put
the Rook behind the pawn and even King
Pawn end games are winning now this King
on A5 can just start walking down the
yellow brick road on that a file and
start to just snap stuff yeah that's
true so Rook F4 is good Rook E2 winning
the H Pawn and then Rook H1 because this
becomes a huge threat and actually H2
should win with Rook A1
A1 oh wow that's that what a game from
Paulina sh well of us she was faster she
had that endgame technique and she went
with it to a three-point lead she takes
a drink from her cup she has earned
every bit of her Advantage right now and
for Levy the best news is that the 5+
one portion it's in the books yeah it's
crazy because you don't even have to
know much about chest and I'm telling
you you could just look at the clocks
and it could tell you who's in the
driver's seat every game that Pina has
won she's been up on the clock at the
end of it every game that that Levy is
won it's been a different it's been the
opposite so the clock times have really
told us who's better and why well we are
getting into a shorter time control so
Casa before we had to break any advice
for Levy and what he should do entering
the three-minute portion play play a
little faster play more confident and
start to ask those questions because
when you ask Pina the questions
sometimes she won't have the answers
it's true can't answer them all but if
you are looking to play chess we do have
an answer for you there is a special
tournament happening later today uh
please do get involved and join us for
the first ever Spirit day chess
tournament in partnership with glad in
support of queer youth within the chess
Community chess.com is hosting a 2hour
blitz arena with prizes for top
finishers this evening at 8:00 p.m.
eastern time to learn more about our
partnership with glad and how to join
the spirit day tournament use the
command spirit in chat now we're heading
to break and when we return the time
patrols get shorter in the championship
match between Levy Rosman and Paulina
Shava we'll be right
[Music]
back chess kid is fun chess is great for
the brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent approved way for your child to
play chess online chess kid is
educational to kids it feels just like
playing but chess is a great way to
learn patience strategy and critical
thinking chess kid features a
comprehensive training program that
guides kids to level up on their way to
Mastery there are more than 50,000 chess
puzzles and a whole library of
entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids chess kid is
easy whether you're a parent helping
your child a coach managing dozens of
kids or a school of hundreds signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
[Music]
for all right that's my
move oh yeah do you want to be black
yes
okay we have a noboy loud chess club
because it feels like in chess sometimes
there's too many boys who are just you
know critical or judgmental it's a
pretty intimidating space or it can be
when you go to a chess club and there's
no other girls there so we want this to
be a place where girls feel comfortable
playing chess doesn't matter if you're
good or um a
beginner that's what the chest cave is
[Music]
for
he
[Music]
[Applause]
he
[Music]
n
[Applause]
[Music]
by
B
[Music]
you've seen the speed Chess
Championship now it's time for the rest
of us to get a turn with no Grand
Masters allowed it's the I'm not a GM
speed Chess
Championship watch your favorite chess
personalities duke it out in chess.com
exciting speed chess format
there will be brillianes L stacking
another po Bishop C3 and Rook a one oh
Rook a one there will be blunders no no
he fell for it see old rivalries this is
how long new
foes with a $115,000 prize pool who will
take home the crown this year he's up 80
and he retin Paulina Shala she moves on
to the final the IMC starts right
[Music]
now and we turn here in the IMA GM speed
Chess Championship Paulin Shava leads
Levy Rosen by three points but Levy he's
been here before in fact in the
semifinals against graditi he also
trailed by up to three point so with his
work cut out for him we know that he's
capable and Kasa most importantly he
knows that he's capable yeah and he was
tring three points going into the bullet
segment and he still has a 3 plus one
segment to play through right now so I
think you know everything's in front of
him and really there's so much match
left he's won every game where he's put
pressure on Paulina on the clock and I
think that's really going to be the key
what could be dangerous for Levy is
Paulina herself said that she's not so
familiar with the 5minute time control
now that she's in her element the title
two Tuesday time control they can just
go at it and we have kakan number five
here we go it it's we're getting close
to that over under Robert I'm actually
I'm starting to feel good about these uh
these these lines I've set but we had
this version of the position before this
uh this line where you play C5 in the
advance really early in a previous
Edition the queen that White Queen got
to the G4 Square through a really Savvy
maneuver with C3 Queen A4 and queen G4 I
do not think Levy is going to allow it
this time well look at this instead of
playing C3 play the castles first and
only now plays C3 after Levy committed
his Queen to C7 so I like this queen A4
check idea going over to the G4 Square
uh might not be necessary though because
black is lagging behind in development
yeah and again I think really the
problem for black in these positions is
the pawn E5 serves a very annoying wedge
for attacking chances and so it's you
don't feel good about castling there uh
on the king side and black WFT to delay
it by making these moves like Knight
Knight F5 or Bishop B7 Bishop B7 or D7
as Lev is making right now and he's
going to keep his ke on E8 for longer
than you think this does not look very
pleasant at least to my eyes for black
C4 given a question mark but it is a
very natural move I think the reason why
the engine doesn't like it is after Pawn
takes C4 you either carve out the D5
score wow okay that move I am surprised
by because I've I learned that when you
have this type of position you want it
to be open for black not closed in the
center like this yeah and I I think the
problem here for black is how are you
going to unravel your minor pieces both
the bishop on D7 the Knight on E7 and
then that Bishop on f8 they all
basically needed some life I would have
put the bishop on the C6 square and not
oh Robert we have to point out that
Bishop on F4 allowed this move F5 to be
played it was like a OneStop shop
opportunity where the bishan F4 would
have been hanging and so the queen could
have taken there was no aant so that was
a bit of a Miss there but just so tough
to see this is 3 plus one folks yeah
actually it's a really good point so
instructive that I'm going to ask for an
analysis board for the first time today
because black is cramped lacking oxygen
in the position so if we go back to that
moment Bishop F4 was given an X because
F5 as Kasa points out the bishop is
loose normally you just take on pan you
open the position up but here you would
drop that Bishop on F4 so Kasa well
spotted by you that was one opportunity
for black to gain some critical space
instead in the game we saw natural
looking development but as white pushes
the black pieces back F5 no longer works
the same because when white takes on
pant here then this bishop on E7 is
loose so once you take on F4 I take on
E7 and clearly white is a side for
Choice with the black king being hunted
yeah and now that that was basically
that little opportunity was missed it's
really hard to figure out again where is
this King on E8 going how is black going
to generate play A4 I like from a
practical standpoint you're basically
spoiling the structure uh White
structure that is on the queen side and
maybe you have some Avenues in with some
Knight A5 or Rook B2 at some point
although I love a rook B1 Rook B5
exchange sacrifice at some point I I
just I feel like it could be on the
cards one day I'm partial to that as
well the queen comes up to D3 saying
Levy uh do you want a castle in this
game I don't think right now because his
bishop and queen were lined up for
checkmate and Kasa Rook B we go step one
here comes Rook B5 the other thing about
that idea by the way is that Bishop one
C6 is probably Black's strongest minor
piece right now oh my God please play B5
Pina play Rook B5 all right she's
preparing it I okay that's allowed we
can prepare it the Knight can come to E4
but Rook B5 is begging to be played you
get a protected passer you fix your Pawn
structure and boom it's on the board and
you deserve a huge shout out double
exclamation point and it's deserved
because this move says I am giving up a
rook for a bishop that sounds like a bad
trade you're UND doubling your pawns as
white getting a protected pass pawn and
in a closed position Rooks aren't
necessarily worth more than minor pieces
we say Rooks are Five Knights are three
but when it's closed Knights are
actually good and this bishop on C2 it
could go out to the A4 square at some
point and the black king could be in
danger and watch out for Queen H seven
here yeah again these are protected
passers these A and B pawns Robert in
your in the previous game before the end
of the 5 plus1 segment you were just
demonstrating these wonderfully uh
aesthetic lines with sacking the rook
and having two pawns on the sixth rank
these pawns aren't that far away so A4
would be my my you know option every day
of the week just to make sure those
pawns are connected and then that Queen
on C7 would be Tethered to the A5 square
and look at Pao retreating Bishop D2
because her Queen now stares up into the
position The Black Queen slides back and
she goes after a different Pawn look at
Black's loose position here and here
comes the Aon that you call for and by
the way Kasa look at the clock my
goodness I mean this is really really
beautiful strategic play and she's up on
time again that is the key if W pina's
up on time you have to like her chances
and it's because she's getting really
great positions that she can navigate
well now that Queen trade I wouldn't
have gone for that King on D7 was
exposed and vulnerable although
practically speaking now these pawns
should still Ru the day right now that
uh or they not rule not Ru the day rule
the day they are dominant and another
pass Pawn for good measure so white has
a pass a pawn a pass B Pawn and a past H
Pawn I see the engines saying that black
is okay here I think practically
speaking it's such a difficult position
but Bishop G5 is a good start Kasa
because you're trying to eliminate
White's grasp of this A5 Square
something has changed a little bit here
because a few moves ago I didn't think
we had to even remotely be worried about
black Central pawns becoming menacing
and now they're kind of becoming menaces
to society uh now that that Bishop has
left the E1 A5 diagonal how do you push
A5 you don't um so it's going to be
tricky conversion although now C5 looks
like it's dropping off well E5 also
dropping of you can choose how you want
to capture in this position I think that
that's critical pawn and also the B Pawn
can be scored to the other side she
takes on G5 we see the engine it's
saying not the best choice but still
good enough at this stage and how is
Paulina going to do is the H Pawn is it
the B Pawn is it the a pawn which one
Robert H6 H7 looked really nice to me
because h8 Queen results in a fork o
that is really actually nasty to uncover
there so King D6 by Le that's a good
move the Knight comes to C6 now A6 A7
will be defended
yeah Bishop D3 just defend that C4 Pawn
keep everything under control again that
A6 now we again we're at that point now
two connected passers on the sixth rank
we talked about it already the six of
the third it's just a problem folks it's
a huge problem and H7 is available if
this Knight Retreats the F5 Pawn drops
so Levy loses on time but he also lost
on the board Rook B5 a shot H around the
world because she sacrificed the rook
and Levy might have to talk about that
one but right now he needs to let his
moves do the talking Costa he's down by
four points and is that kacan number six
I mean I'm telling you this this could
have been called the kacan Invitational
because that is the Vibes we're on right
now uh we got a totally new setup F3 is
an aggressive line the fantasy variation
is what it's called I do not know why
it's called that way but it is kind of
Fantastical um again you're pushing the
F Pawn that early but you're trying to
maintain the center um I think this is
up Levy's wheelhouse stylistically so
I'm a fan what I'm a fan of though in
quicker time controls is making my
opponent prove that they have
compensation because compensation is
often quite vague what does that really
mean how do they seese control of the
board in a way that compensates for a
pawn and here black is up a pawn and the
question becomes does levy have enough
and for Alina what does she do about her
development because right now she is
behind yeah usually compensation for me
and I think for folks at home that are
trying to think about it I think if you
have two or other three elements in your
favor it kind of justifies it so if you
have central control that might be uh
one thing in your favor and I think
white definitely did before paulina's
really brilliant expansion in the center
just now I would have said for sure that
would have been compensation if you have
a lead in development that's another
thing and so I think there is
compensation just based on those two
factors then the queen was chased around
a bunch that's another thing wh's Rooks
are connected that's kind of another
thing and so there definitely is
compensation but the question is there
more than that and now it's actually
material equality because after this
Pawn took on D5 P says let me get my
king to safety and now that we see these
pawns swap off it is even material but
it's not a completely balanced position
we have another game Kasa where this
Pawn is on F3 so the dark squares might
be a long-term issue for white to deal
with yeah and again I mean we can I take
you can I can you give me some lottery
numbers because just prophetic stuff
that F3 Pawn sticks out like a sore
thumb the longer the game goes on and
you know paulina's managed to navigate
the mess that Levy basically initiated
from the jump very very nicely a thing
you see strong players do a lot is punt
on the material to catch up in some
other another Arena and it was the
development she punted on the pawn to
catch him on development and now all of
a sudden her Rooks are connected she has
a pawn that's in the center everything
is kind of making
sense it is indeed and what's
problematic for white is like in the
Scandinavian when you have these pawns
disconnected like this the knight's on
C3 black may stick a knight on C4 at the
right moment so first she trades on D3
now she can play very simple chess here
put a rook on E8 put a rook on d8 I
would definitely take Black's position
and this Pawn on F3 it is not on a good
Square yeah um and and now yeah there's
a lot of opportunities to expand Rook d8
makes a lot of sense I would have gone
Knight B6 and kind of caught The Rook
left the Rook hanging on B7 for a little
while but um don't play Knight B6 now
Queen takes seven it Queen takes F7
would be Checkmate in two so Queen C4 is
a really smart move and that's why
you're getting seeing the exclaim there
it freezes that Knight on D7 fantastic
move from Levy because this position was
heading in paulina's Direction Knight D5
is a nice response cutting off the
diagonal threatening his Bishop on E3
and if Knight takes and the pawn takes
back that'd be good but this apparently
was a blunder so Kasa Bishop D2 a normal
looking move it's a retreating move
apparently Paulina could take advantage
yeah not sure the reputation of this one
yet I'm guessing maybe there's a capture
on D4 and then the Rook on E8 opens up
but I'm not seeing the final death nail
here I like e takes D4 because white has
to play Knight E4 and the queen does
have an escape Square via A3 so that's
one opportunity another is maybe your
move Knight to B6 to trap that rook in
there you can choose either Knight and
D4 will drop in most of these positions
so this is starting to be very pleasant
for Paulina and Robert if that Queen
drops back to like D3 or something does
Queen A6 trap The Rook question mark oh
so you just go back here and The Rook is
stuck yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah who that
could be an issue so Queen D3 does keep
an eye on the A6 Square
oh Queen A6 The Rook is caught Ohi finds
it and Levy he's going to lose the rook
and you know sometimes we joke we like
to imitate people that we respect but
you know I'm not going to shout about
The Rook this time that Rook is just
gone yeah and again all of White's
pieces are kind of just loose like the
bishop on D2 is also unprotected the the
the knights on C3 and E2 are a little
bit clumsy so even if the could somehow
navigate to a safe square like if you
could pick up the Rook on B7 like you've
done in previous instances and just put
on C1 for instance it would still be a
problematic position because wh's piece
in the center are not coordinated well
and so there was a capture on D5 and
after Pawn takes as you mentioned the
Rook is hanging and if you save The Rook
down goes the Knight on E2 exactly your
point and after Rook takes B6 I think
she should take this Knight because the
bishop and The Rook are both hanging
that is super Savvy and she has the time
to think and figure this out she's up on
time again she is going to take this
night because it win her a full piece
which is better than a rook for a minor
and unfortunately for Levy he's down to
15 seconds he might need to throw in the
towel because that is a full piece and
now Paulina Shala is Up by Five Points
in the match yeah and don't discount
confidence and momentum okay we have a
shift from the kakan to an Owens defense
I was going to say French because
started with E6 but then it went to B
six and this combination is the Owens
defense Robert I know you are not a fan
of the French are you fan of the Owens I
actually play the Owens sometimes in
online Blitz and bullet but Lawrence
tried this against Paulina so Paulina
undoubtedly has looked at it since that
match and we see her get the bishop pair
once again she can safely Castle her
King this battery on the diagonal here
if the Knight moves it could be a
Checkmate but this bishop can slide back
I just like this for white this was
giving me scandy Vibes because we had
this bishop B4 take C3 position in the
Scandinavian earlier and that was
actually one of the games Levy actually
had the upper hand for almost for
basically almost all of it and in that
position there the D4 Pawn was a bit
loose um she uh Paulina went for early
D5 break and in that game Levy also
castled long so I'm wondering if he's
actually going to look to maybe quickly
develop the Knight to C6 and Castle
along and generate that pressure on D4
there are tactics because the queen on
G6 and the bishop on B7 are bearing down
on
G2 and so Knight H4 if play Queen E4 you
lose the game because the bishop would
go to F3 the bishop still could go out
to F3 don't tell me this would be a draw
by repetition that would be something I
think she I'd be surprised I would be
surprised but that that definitely is an
option um here um Bishop D2
yeah sensible no not only is it sensible
it's brilliant because Knight H4 would
now Force Queen let's get an analysis
board here that's disgusting this move
is so clever uh if we just make a very
logical looking move like Castle's King
side Knight H4 you don't have any of
these squares available to you so Queen
goes E4 and Bishop F3 hits the queen and
the bishop behind it so take my knight I
get your bishop and then your Rook that
is really Savvy stuff that actually kind
of deserves an exclam um the bishop d2
move even though uh you know it didn't
register as such that's a really really
strong move and then now the pawn on D4
is more secure with the C3 move so
everything's kind of covered and white
is definitely for choice and um it's
impressive stuff although I love Levy's
decision to Castle along it's what he
has to do to justify the play and I
think there are still some drama to be
had on G2 because of that battery and
there will be some tactics available
this is Paulina style right Levy you're
trying to Checkmate me you need some
wins let's get those Queens off the
board and see who's better Knight E4
says no Queen trade for you F5 can
always be a follow-up but I would just
move my Bishop out the way probably to
F4 and I can always drop back parking on
G3 if I need to to make my king feel
safer yeah it just gives you an extra
layer of security little little little
picnic blanket little uh it's a little
nice thing to lie on and be secure and
essentially here you know the queen
trade was probably objectively Levy's
best choice but for the match situation
and from the stylist perspective it's
not the ideal choice so Queen F6 another
excellent move and here we go we're
having a mess right now Knight takes D4
Bishop A6 I think is the only move
Robert no way and she didn't plan this
that's clear because she's paused but
Knight takes D4 earned a exclamation
point and your point CA that the bishop
and the Knight are loose and black just
stole a pawn she finds Bishop A6 and
that move is
fantastic now to be honest I don't know
what happens next because everything is
The Rook on F1 will be loose in a second
do you do you move that after the bishop
takes on A6 do you do you do you take on
the Knight on D4 it's it's so messy I I
think you have to take the Knight on D4
but I'm afraid to evaluate this well the
good news for white is that you're going
to be up a minor piece for a pawn and
after Bishop takes F1 I think take back
and if Rook takes D4 this is my
Essential point that there's a queen A8
check and your Rook is loose on the
other side so it's getting really messy
we could get a position Casa where black
has a rook in two pawns for two minor
pieces that's about even by point value
but it really depends on the ensuing
position yeah I I feel like yeah because
of that you have to take with the queen
on D4 right in that line that you're
describing to invite a queen trade and
then you take the sting out of Queen A8
check if the Rooks are still protected
and um you know the Rook on h8
specifically would be protecting that
line I actually prefer the two Rooks
there but okay that's a moot point this
is a totally different position okay so
Queen G4 is now met by Rook taste D4
this is clever stuff which means that D5
if she plays D5 here and is able to keep
her extra piece I don't know what's
going to stop her and she and this folks
is human play Queen F4 I mean uh
basically that was a tough move to play
Under duress and look at this Levy is
now up on the clock and that again has
been The Telltale sign of who wins and
loses these games
as Pina gets lower she'll have to make
some tough decisions here and Levy's
pieces are starting to work that Bishop
on B7 still looking at G2 Levy's getting
a piece back right now it's just a
question of how the reason why is after
I mean if this bishop C3 looks like it's
good for white because both Rooks are
under attack but look at Levy if we can
I don't know if we have time for
analysis board but are bringing up very
very quickly that at this stage Bishop
takes H4 looks like a free rook but you
get checkmated because I steal your Pawn
PA I go right back and then I bring my
Rook up here and you can only block with
your Rook cuz I stole your pawn and that
would have been Checkmate so a Brant
save there from Levy the tactics worked
in his favor and let's get to the live
board quickly as Pina she is now down
several pawns she is trying to save this
game Kasa do you believe in the drawing
chances of the opposite color Bishops I
don't because heavy pieces are on the
board when you H when you have a rook on
the board or a queen uh these positions
don't have the same drawing Tendencies
as you'd imag
otherwise and so and now these light
scores are super weak I'd walk this king
king C6 King B5 King A4 why would you
trade Rooks though why why trade right
now you didn't need to do it you just
said the presence of the heavy pieces
gave black better chances and King to E3
unfortunately it looks like the black
king is in now A4 was necessary from
Paulina movo but she's got two seconds
can hardly blame her for not finding all
of the accurate defensive moves yeah um
and it seems like there will be enough
because now it'll be three
pawns three pawns indeed although how do
you win this game because A6 Bishop C7
B5 I've stopped all of your pawns yeah
although there's going to be some
breakthrough eventually with E5 and then
if F takes E5 F4
right okay the engine's not liking and
Bishop E5 but that's not the move so
King B1 now you're now you now your king
can actually migrate towards the the
queen side or sorry the king side ah so
you're going to give up the a pawn bring
your king back around and then go after
these pawns over here that's really
smart the problem essentially is that
even though the pawns right now are both
protected on on H well they can be
protected on F4 and H4 eventually there
will be some lever connected to E5 and
that E5 break is going to result in uh
either the H Pawn dropping or the black
F Pawn becoming a new potential Queen if
white ever plays F takes E5 and so
that's essentially what Levy has to to
navigate here bring the keep the pawns
protected and then walk the king over
and that's what he's doing now E5 E5
well timed by Levy great explanation
from you and this should be a winning
end game because the white king and
Bishop can't defend on both sides of the
board very easily yeah and it's there's
this concept isn't it like of the pants
or something like pants legs it's like a
as long as you the trousers right as
long as the trousers can be uh contained
then the the bishop kind of has its has
its day but not today
not today it is now 7 to3 Levy Rosman
gets a much needed Victory he shakes his
head a bit but I thought he played that
game extremely well he created the
complications and he was able to come
out on top and I think we have carolan
number six or seven here
seven I'm losing track honestly but the
carakan is the opening of the day yeah
so basically this line we have not seen
before this H this Advance with H4 is
really really fun and Lead need to have
really aggressive attacking positions
for white C4 this is an incredibly
dangerous move I've actually looked at
this Robert you can take on B2 and get
these uh and and try to grab that pawn
but the positions are so dangerous to
defend and so I think this is exactly uh
to Levy's uh liking and essentially you
play Knight gf3 you castle and you just
try to break through in the center and
jump on black before he's developed and
this bishop on G5 is in a perfect
location uh it can't kick be kicked out
by a pawn very easily you're never
playing F6 and inviting the queen in and
so that's going to be a thorn in Black
side but Levy I think his preparation
finished at that moment he went for a
think here and he made an inaccurate
move but one that still gives white a
goodlooking position you know what's
funny Knight E2 actually is the move in
some positions where black takes on B2
and so I think maybe Levy was just
imagining it being the same position but
you could actually have developed it to
the more active Square on F3 because
because the pawn on B2 wasn't captured
and then that defends the E5 Pawn so
this is a better version for pina than
you typically get here and again if
black can get the Queens off the board
then you start to feel the E5 Pawn is
overextended that there might be some
Targets in the position but with those
Queens on the board it's just you know
black is literally holding on to for
deer life and Levy's fortunate that D3
doesn't win on the spot because Queen A4
check would turn the tables this King is
M it thanks to this bishop on G5 so you
have to take this Pawn on D5 with the
Knight it's so tempting to go for D3
trying to get this forkin but you
actually lose the game if you make that
push yeah and Knight takes E5 now that
Knight on D5 is really nicely cemented
you're going to block this check with
Queen C6 and again if those Queens come
off the board the worst is over doesn't
this remind you of the first game of the
match
where with the white pieces created
those split pawns and he was able to
play a really nice game before Paulina
was able to turn it around in Levy's
time trouble yeah it actually does um
King D7 is getting a question mark but
you know a lot of times you learn you
don't actually need to Castle uh if the
Queens are off the board because the
king will ultimately start to move move
along to the the center anyway the
reason it's it's it's maybe not ideal
here is because that King actually can
be harassed and we see it Knight B3 is
an excellent move Knight E4 is in the
agenda and with the Knight on e4 also uh
in the center there the D5 Square will
be very very sensitive and this Rook
lift Rook H3 is also incredibly clever
move because you can slide along the
third Rank and make some stuff happen
yeah this Rook could even slide over to
A3 after this Knight goes into C5 as it
has I would be capturing this Knight I
don't want to allow both Knights to
plant their themselves into the heart of
my position so I would capture this
Knight but clearly white is better it's
about proving it at this stage I I guess
you could say po likes
nightmares oh did you just take one from
DA's book um yeah I'm not going to I'm
not going to do that again this match um
moving on um yeah this Rook on H3 needs
to slide into action I don't know if
it's D3 or F3 or B3 but all of White's
pieces seem to be working um except that
rook and maybe even that bishon G5 if
that Bish if the bishon B6 ever to
captur on C5 you will see a bishop D2 to
A5 check sighting and I think that would
be wrap so that's why Pina is actually
not taking
anymore she's playing very good defense
at this stage it's clearly better for
white but the advantage has remained the
same not much to it at this stage A4 is
one of these moves that you want to play
but you're worried that you're going to
lose that pawn in short order so Rook to
B8 C I have to say Pina she's playing
really stubborn defense yeah and that
Knight on D5 is the real MVP of the
defense here because it's entrenched in
the center it can't be shifted and
that's essentially what's holding the
position together although still uh you
have to like Levy's chances here and
he's just got to play a little bit
faster put the pressure on the clock and
I think good things will happen although
now Pina has maximized as much as she
could on the queen side and decides it's
time to go for some exchanges remember
how we talked about the E5 Pawn being
overextended can be vulnerable here it's
starting to look that way a bit and this
Knight is attacked once if you could
attack it again it's kind of oh it has
the E4 Square I was going to say it was
trapped but no it is not trapped and
Bishop D2 did take away this Rook coming
to A5 yeah it's a weird position
actually because both sides have their
weaknesses like the E5 Pawn could be a
bit of a Target so could the A4 Pawn um
but the minor pieces can't really be
shifted from both sides right the
knights on D5 and F5 are really
entrenched and the N C5 was actually not
a bad piece either so um I actually
don't know like who I'd rather have in a
practical
game I think I prefer black position
just because of all of White's pawns
being on dark squares and the bishop is
a defensive piece and King D2 play the
engine does not
approve I think it's just because peace
trades favor Black right um uh maybe
Rook B3 I thought was yeah more more to
the point is F7 just hanging F7 is
hanging but she's going after
E5 no she's going D5 check she's going
to get get on the offensive right oh no
okay I don't know what's going on here
that's clear Knight takes C5 is not a
threat right because Bishop F4 would pin
so really well spotted Rook C4 noticing
that I don't even have to defend E5 and
at some moment Knight h8 to go out for
the G6 Pawn could be annoying here so
King E2 Knight takes E5 as you said not
an option with Bishop F4 available but
now Knight D4 check where's the this
King going yeah I'm a little bit worried
this Knight getting to B3 is pretty
annoying because it uh kind of looks at
the bishman C1 there's maybe some Rook
B1 ideas these Knights are jumping and
this is a little bit dangerous now
because again Pina is up on the clock in
the suing time trouble but maybe I'm
speaking too soon 19 18
17 and she goes after The Rook The Rook
slides back she can go Knight D4 again
but she wants more she might be playing
for wind despite being down a pawn
because the white king is in what looks
like a mating net but Black's pawns
might fall off and I think what she's
noticing now is Rook D4 Knight D4 allows
Rook D2 just trading and all these end
games are going to be winning for white
yes and Knight to C4 played this Pawn E6
is dropping because the Knight is kicked
out of D4 Levy's about to take a second
game in a row yeah and he had he's up on
the clock which is a great sign he's
basically going Pac-Man with these Pawn
this Knight just taking all the pawns
and uh oh
just the a pawn to navigate that is a
knight C4 is a really tricking move
bring now E5 PA hangs it's it's a
different game it's a different game now
the pawns are being targeted all of them
because Knight E3 check to F5 will go
after these pawns over here and she goes
in that direction apparently that was a
mistake I I was looking that way too but
I thought that the the pawns would get
Frozen and maybe that's not enough that
now H5 is covering all of the pawns and
now E2 all the pawns are covered it was
able to work back and that is going to
be good enough for Levy he's keeping
Pace on the clock and it's Pina Who's
down to her final second yeah now Knight
G1 just covering all the pawns and uh
that smooth sailing you can't you can't
actually improve without pushing the
pawn without allowing the white pawns to
push and that's what's happening H6 H7
Queen and look at Levy with the fist
pump there you can see how much it means
to him he was down by five he's trimmed
it to three he is right back in this
match yeah the comeback Trail has begun
and let's not forget Levy is I would
dare say a favorite in the bullet
portion so he was trolling by three
points uh in in his match against
against Greg shahadi and ultimately
managed to equalize extremely quickly um
I think honestly if if it's in that two
to three uh game margin he'll still have
excellent chances in the bullet
I'm with you there Levy he is down by
just three points he can breathe a sigh
of relief because he's in Striking
Distance and in this current position
Levy played a G6 on move one Ean K his
Bishop early I would say that he has a
good fight this is one of those
positions where you just take what's in
front of you it's not theoretical and
it's going to be the side who plays
better who will be able to obtain the
upper hand yeah and I think also it it
takes uh real humility to switch gears
when something isn't working in the
middle of a match that kocan that that
advanced business with C5 it just wasn't
working and so now he's just moving
around just a little bit keeping Pina
guessing and you know it's hard to react
when someone's posing these concrete
challenges and I love this queen H4 move
CU it looks at the E4 Pawn looks at H3
in some positions and uh Pina is trying
to stabilize she's trying to trade
pieces and essentially um just keep
things under control because she feels
she's losing it she still is up three
points but the trend has been going in
Levy's Direction shout out to nearly 30k
of you watching across all platforms
whether it's twitch YouTube I don't know
we on Tik Tok I'm I'm old I don't follow
this Stu all the things all the things
we all the things and for those of you
who are watching let us know do you
think that Levy can come back because
Paulina was up by five many of you were
thinking that she would run away with
this title now Levy is back to a
familiar territory he was down by three
points against Greg shahadi he won that
semi-final to earn his spot here and c I
have to say rookie five an excellent
move from Levy neither side wants to
budge in the center yeah it's so funny
cuz both sides are doing what they do
best I think Levy is keeping the queen
on entertaining attacking Chances with
H5 H4 Pina played an early B4 and then
A4 A5 fixing the queenside Pawns of
black on light Square so if the Queens
do come off the board and there's a
skirmish those pawns on the queen side
might ultimately be targets for the
white Bishop so both sides are basically
doing what they do best and there's also
good clock management here so I'm
curious to see what happens next okay G3
played after H4 we will see G4 as a
response I don't like the look of giving
the black queen the F4 Square so ASA is
there a world where she allows white uh
this Pawn to be captured on G3 and
White's Pawn structure ISO in the center
yeah it's it's basically like CH make a
decision from two really not undesirable
options I think I'm going to keep the
pawns uh tethered together and I'm going
to go G4 and cringe that I you know
basically create this swiss cheese
Dynamic but okay Pina goes for another
route she's I I guess she's going to
take on G3 with the F Pawn but I don't
love that she could take with the Rook
too but again that F4 Square weak weak
very very available essentially so um
yeah but maybe Rook takes G3 is the
sensible choice I would have taken with
the F Pawn like she did this position is
starting to look very good for black you
talked about this earlier it's about
Pawn Islands white has three Pawn
Islands from the a to C file the E Pawn
isolated means that white needs to use
all of her pieces to defend it and then
the two over here meanwhile black has
just two Pawn islands and has the
bathtub formation that's what I like to
call this here uh this bathtub formation
usually very solid hard to get at i'
like Levy's position and this could be a
third straight win if he plays his cards
right yeah and I must say if the queen
trade does actually happen on Black's
terms with Queen takes F6 check King
takes F6 we might have a king of the
hill sighting cuz that King could just
uh install itself on E5 and really be
pretty cemented it's like almost like an
outpost for the king I do like this H4
move though uh the idea just basically
carving out some dark squares um
preventing uh further encroach for for
black if they black had any ideas a G5
or some Rook h8 Rook H5 you're just
making it a little bit trickier so
there's a tension here both sides don't
want to trade Queens on their opponent's
terms so they're guys chilling and and
it's a kind of a tug-of war to see who's
going to Blink first and we see the
Rooks go up and back for both sides Levy
he's down to 40 seconds to paulina's
minute and a half I could see him trying
to make a draw by repetition Bud he goes
Queen to E5 I like this no white does
not want to trade Queens that's taking
on Black's terms and this isolated Pawn
will be bad and as you keep noting black
does not want to take on D4 because you
fix White's Pawn structure in the center
watch out though there's a shot on H4
there yeah it's it's funny there's a
little tickling happening here but I I
don't think you want to keep your
continue to keep your King on H2 because
Rook takes H4 continues to be that idea
and are we going to get our first
repetition of the match I feel like this
is one of our first draws of the match I
don't remember any other ones but a draw
does feel like a fair result at this
stage and if I'm Paulina oh she plays on
I don't like that choice she is playing
with fire right now she's making the
decision based on the clock times though
and I got to respect it if if she's up
on the clock she feels like she has some
chance and no we're going to get the
repetition I think that was an important
game for pina though she had lost two in
a row the momentum was kind of swing
away from her she stemmed the tide and
now Levy get going pull going deep into
the bag and now going for Knight C3 F4
we're getting a Vienna
Levy uh taught a lot of players for POG
Champs taught them the Vienna it's a
very dangerous opening for both sides
the reason why is white is missing this
very critical F Pawn it opens this
diagonal from H4 to E1 also opens the
other diagonal for where white usually
castles but we see that white has the
lead in development Queen is out Bishop
can join the party King can Castle along
and it's the black king that can come
under Fire and I think it it prends
perfectly to Levy style and that's why
Pina is like we're going to trade queens
and get you to my territory so it's so
funny the tug of war that's happening
now you see levie likes these attacking
positions Paulina likes the technical
positions and she's going to get the
position she wants this game but this
looks like it's backfired for Levy then
because the queen trade can happen this
bishop right now can go out to F5 if you
want I don't think I would take on C2
that's playing in Levy style as you
mentioned but Paulina she plays it
safely she now can take this Pawn on E5
as the Knight is no longer pinned yeah
and I I think it's a smart choice not to
take on C2 uh not all pawns are created
equal and you know development uh King
safety those things matter a bit more
and so I think she's making the right
choice to steer it towards those
technical Waters again we have this
queen tension neither side really wants
to take and you see if black takes an F3
basically helping to develop White's
Knight so that's basically why you're
seeing this uh this little standoff situ
situation here and um yeah the question
is what do you do about your D5 Pawn
because it is hanging now that White
Castle it's hanging through the Queens
A6 played if Bishop takes Bishop takes
the D5 Pawn is defended but that could
leave black with a poor light Square
Bishop I would go for that I would trade
Queens I would take this Knight and then
just develop my knight out to E2 and say
some of these dark squares are looking
pretty juicy that Knight is awfully
hoppy yeah the Knight definitely can
Nestle itself on F4 or D4 but I think
Paulina will be able to handle this
pretty reasonably I mean I think you
develop your Bishop you play Rook d8 um
it it take it looks a little bit like a
Berlin to me to be honest um um you know
we see this in the in the ru Lopez
sometimes where black is the two Bishops
and a a weird King position but the
Queens are off so it's not a huge deal
and yeah I think you just keep the
Bishops here you just go Bishop
D7 I thought the Knight would get more
access and now that it hasn't been able
to land on a good Square in enemy
territory I'm starting to like pulling
this position because the bishop hair is
stronger this E5 Pawn is loose and in
some of these end games Kasa you brought
this up several times today look at
these double pawns over here that is bad
news if say all the pieces let's the
ones I'm putting in red the minor pieces
and the Rooks if those are off the board
black could just be winning in the
ensuing position yeah no question about
it although Rook F1 do you think the
idea there is to go Rook F4 and take
that E4 Pawn cuz it does it's it's it's
a move that makes sense but there's a
little bit of greed in that and a little
bit of a compromising a coordination I'm
not sure if that's a way to go and also
black can still cast along let's not
forget uh this bishop coming to D7
actually does facilitate that
possibility and I'm not so sure it'd be
ideal for white to start to hunt for
that E4 Pawn well she starts with Bishop
H3 asking that Rook where are you going
Rook F2 looks natural to me but then
Rook d8 you can't Castle Queens that's
one annoying thing just because the F7
Pawn will hang although if you play Rook
E1 then I might reconsider and Castle
but Rook F2 protects the Rook keeps n on
F7 and Rook d8 would be my followup it
looks like the Berlin and much like
these Berlin end games if you're not
getting the activity you need I would
say black is the side for Choice yeah
and it's basically like a Berlin with
the better Pawn structure for the black
side right so that's uh that's kind of
the the difference here but Levy keeping
pieces on the board rookie one not
trying to trade any Rooks right now
every piece trade will favor Black and
that's kind of the dynamic I think we
could say in almost every game between
Levy and Paulina peace trades favor
Paulina uh initiative favors Levy and H5
speaking of initiative Paulina wants to
throw that pawn forward but Knight F5
happens at an inopportune moment for
Paulina her Bishop is hanging this Pawn
G7 is loose is she going to play Bishop
f8
oh my goodness she's thinking it's a
Berlin all the pieces here with the
exception of that Bishop on H3 are
oriented like a Berlin even this H5 move
there's so many positions in the Berlin
where the Rook activates along the H
file the problem is this E4 Pawn is just
dropping off and Rook takes E4 is played
and I think that Paulina has little
choice but to boot this Knight out of G6
but that gives white the F6 square at
the in the near future to take advantage
of I do not like this for poina she's
down under 20 seconds she needs to find
a move now yeah I'm getting major swiss
cheese Vibes here I mean the F6 Square
the H6 Square the G7 Square there is all
very very soft and um hard for uh white
white hard for black to finish the
development
too and Rook to D7 quickly played she
has the light squares under her control
this bishop can slide back to E6 and
let's not forget that White's extra Pawn
its presence not entirely felt at the
moment is this doubled Pawn on C3 so
white does need to be accurate otherwise
the advantage is out the window I would
go B before to just make it difficult
for black to finish their development
and the point is I'm cool with Bishop E7
and trading the dark Square Bishops but
not anything else you called it played
and then Paulina quickly scoots her
Bishop back to E6 the King goes out to
B2 and C5 played she wants to open up
this bishop A3 seems very sensible yeah
and now D6 is a major major uh weakness
for later in the game don't be surprised
if a knight gets there one day C5 was a
bit of a risky
Choice well Pina with mid time in her
clock she goes for activity the Knight
goes back to G2 so likely up to F4 and
well the advantage is going up and up in
Levy's favor this King might be
checkmated on E8 yeah it's just exposed
it's it's it's a dangerous spot Bishop
H6 very sneakily attacking
D2 again look at the time look at the
time and she tries to use the presence
of the Bishops of opposite color to give
herself drawing chances what she needs
is her King on C8 if her King were on C8
I would say she's got good chances to
hold right now I'm worried because at
some moment oh that I don't like because
K get now the king gets out there are
some drawing Chan now although the A5
here the the presence of heavy pieces
the presence of Rooks means this is not
a simple to hold whatsoever although
Rook C6 now maybe forc to trade Rook C7
Rook D7 trading those r
Rooks right you you said Rooks she says
what Rooks and now it's Levy who has
less time and if he's not careful B
takes A4 and black could play for a win
and I think Pina can make moves faster
just shuffling the bishop uh oh and the
A5 will open up here who but the king oh
no the king is just going to take
everything oh my goodness and whose
pawns will run fast I think black say G5
and
H4 oh my goodness G5 G5
she's going after the pawn directly she
wants it she doesn't want to but now it
looks the king
active oh my God this is a
race how do you go B7 you have to take
it you have to take it oh my God the
black pawn two connected pawns the
bishop on on D6 is out of the game oh my
goodness she's trying to use the H Pawn
it's over oh my God H3
H2 you can't stop
it here they
come oh my goodness I oh my goodness and
the bishop and the Pauls are perfect
squares that is the worst part for Levy
oh my
God all right that is a major turning
point Paulina won a Time scramble where
she was initially down that has not
happened yet and that is a massive
massive momentum shift and the reason
that she was able to not just survive
but even win is because Levy allowed
that King and then the black Rook to
escape by trading on D7 so that's a
moment that Levy will certainly regret
and now he's back to his kind of Cy
openings he's playing in my style sort
of the hippo the rat whatever you want
to call it it doesn't look very nice in
general But It's tricky in Blitz chest
yeah and Levy needs to snatch back that
momentum because it's a four-point
deficit although this position is very
very dangerous for black because white
is going to connect their Rooks first
they're going to cast along and they're
a lot of piece in the center that are
whites and a lot of black p are still on
the eighth Rank and by a lot you're
talking about these then I'm putting in
red a completely underdeveloped
situation for black and Castle Queen
side Bishop E4 the light squares are
whites for the taking I think black
might lose an exchange quite quickly
yeah there are tactics Galore here F4
it's so funny so so often you know when
you talk to people you say you play on
the side that you're better and this
white was better in the center but just
castling would have been such a such
much a much better move in that position
than playing F4 although you still have
to like White's chances given all the
open lines yeah for a speed chest game
I'd rather have the safer King rather
than the extra material and we see
Bishop E4 played staring at this rook in
the corner The Rook should probably move
don't go to A7 that would be a sloppy
Square as White Castles and there's too
much pressure down the dile I just feel
like black position is much more
challenging to work with yeah and Bishop
C6 is also really trick you pin that
Knight on D7 you ask a question to that
Bishop on E5 would actually be deao
unprotected and um yeah they're still
castling along on the agenda Bishop C6
is an excellent move right now and with
Pina out to a four-point lead once again
she would love to make it five and Levy
he can't tilt that last game is going to
frustrate him he was actually the one up
upon and yet he lost it so he can't just
throw in the towels he needs to keep
fighting a rook D1 another good move I'm
worried about Black's King why Rook D1
and not cast long is there something I'm
missing there Robert was there a queen
trade maybe takes takes and queen G5
okay that was the dynamic I was like why
wouldn't you connect your Rooks it makes
a lot of sense Pina actually for once
wants to keep the Queens on that is
quite the role
reversal she needs it for the attack and
Knight of6 played and apparently that
was a mistake it earns a question mark
Kasa Bishop Bishop C6 feels pretty
automatic black can't Castle King side
because you get checkmated in eight
different ways and after Bishop C6 what
are you doing about this nasty pin which
leaves E5 hanging yeah I actually have
no
idea I have no idea because you're
basically threatening to win a piece and
it's just so hard to get rid of that pin
I guess you have to start with taking on
F4 but I still not sure after Queen
takes the same problems are persist so
um very very dangerous POS position and
this Knight on C3 might also get in on
the ACT well Levy has to flush out that
Bishop from C6 I would take and as
you're pointing out Knight E4 threatens
Rook takes D7 there are so many tactics
in this position I really feel like
Black's position might just fall apart
in the next turn yeah 94 although again
this K one now is not probably going to
Castle and have any kind of you know
real security and so I could see this
turning a bit um again this is a really
really critical game for Levy if he can
get this Whitt this down to three we've
seen him crawl out of these types of
deficits in the bullet segment more than
once and so this is a really critical
juncture for him to kind of you know
basically bear down and and and and
defend and how do you do it basically
Rook takes D7 Knight F6 these tactics
are in the air I'm leaving these arrows
on the board because Levy has done a few
Rook lifts today I think it's paulina's
turn this Rook coming from H1 to the D5
will be devastating and this queen if it
goes to E7 you drop the C7 Pawn which is
critical because it's a check on D6 and
other things Rook H3 I see what you're
doing you're trying to attack my Pawn
here and defend yours but Rook H3 to D3
I just feel it's automatic that is such
a sappy move and honestly I think Rook
G1 is just as natural but no she finds
Rook H3 which is probably best and wow
what a decision there that is I mean
that's it's it's excellent and
again now does does Rook takes D7 now
work or no yeah Rook takes D7 maybe Rook
she misses it let's get an analysis
board quickly because the players are
about to make a series of moves you
called it Kasa Rook takes D7 was working
if the queen takes there's a fork on F6
if the king takes this Rook slides over
to D3 with check winning the queen
because if you block I simply take and
that's not going to help you out as your
queen and king are in the same line so
Kasa a missed opportunity there for pina
uh we see a rook trade and queen G8
check the Knight now has to slide back I
believe this is anyone's contest oh the
worst is over for sure uh this king of
E1 now is I would say uh just as soft as
it's and as weak as its counterpart on
E8 and the pawn structure you know it's
it's kind of mangled the F2 and H3 pawns
are split you could say the same about
Black's pawns but black has extra
security additional Pawn so again and
and now Pina down on the clock we've
seen this before
is this a free piece that's looks like a
big problem for White Knight D2 might be
the only way to save your knight but
you're going in the wrong direction
Knight C3 with Queen takes B2 that's a
pin that's
that and you got to maybe toss in Rook
d8 check and try to just play that
position out Rook d8 Queen takes f8
Queen takes F7 move the Knight it'll
probably be mostly spite checks and
mostly be in vain but that's the way you
would try to handle it but I think Pina
is going to let this clock run out
and she goes Queen F6 thre rning a
mainen one but Queen takes is checked to
the king Levy Rosman wins that game and
the time is up in the thre minute
portion so Casa when we had to Bull it
it's a three-point lead for Paulina Levy
he's in that Striking Distance that he
knows he's capable of coming back from
yeah that was a clutch clutch Victory by
Levy just now he withstood the danger he
handled the pressure and he put her on
the on the on the clock at a deficit and
now we're in the bullet segment where we
know he's definitely a favorite this is
anyone's game he is a favorite indeed
but Paulina she showed her might in the
quickest of time controls against
Lawrence Trent to get here in the finals
because against Lawrence she was
trailing and had to win on demand in
that last game before sending it to
overtime so Kasa heading into bullet
well Levy he won the last game now it's
paulina's turn what does she need to
change she's got to stay up on that
clock she's going to have to make some
really quick and decisions and trust her
intuition that's going to be the key cuz
Levy is going to throw the kitchen sink
at her and we'll see how it
goes we will see after a break the
players get to relax and we'll also see
some more great chests starting later
this month while hikaro Nakamura is busy
playing in the qar Masters he has one
game to go there he will also be playing
in the grand Swiss along with Anish giri
and the others the women's Grand Swiss
at the same time V shali she's a
superstar in fact she is just earned if
both her and her opponent show up
tomorrow her final grandmas Norm at the
guitar master so it's going to be an
absolute slugfest their are candidates
and women Candon spots on the line you
will not want to miss the action so use
the command Grant Swiss to learn more
and that way you can watch each and
every round tasa and I are going to
quickly go on a break and when we return
it's the last time trol here in the I am
not a GM speeches Championship it's Levy
Rosman AKA Gotham chess against Paulina
shuvalova who you got let us know we'll
be back in a
[Music]
few
jack
[Music]
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com connect your chess.com account
and Twitch account at go. chess.com
connect accounts and bang boom while
you're done 100% adree Bliss forever
more whether you're following our events
on site or on stream type the command
connect in the chat and thank you for
helping bring these shows to
life and queen somewhere just need to
figure out where to knock him out and
1.3 seconds left barely off both of
these players are just almost losing on
the spot Queen D4 check Rook D7 coming
up yep Queen D5 check
Queen care Queen trade trade every
queen1 oh my gosh and let me
SP oh my God what a Swindle because
Robert all he had to do was play Queen
takes F7 with a check it's still
completely winning for black and our is
again a threat and she allows it but F
G5 G8 Queen H
G8 oh my gosh she can play
F6 how did you lose that what a 1964
it's a free piece oh my God
wow don't BL Checkmate oh he time no he
won a beast but he lost the game on time
oh my God I can't take it anymore 98 I
think this is just a draw last time oh
my gosh Greg lost in time he won the
game and Lawrence knows that means he
won the match there's a minute left
Lawrence can actually fully celebrate as
that is a three-point lead it's over
look there a good sign of life from Greg
why would you not do that well because
you want to waste some I think if you're
Eric Rosen you really do want to waste
time off the match clock oh my gosh
stalemate that's why you don't resign
that was stalemate oh my gosh oh
she can't pre moove in those
situations oh my goodness he wants takes
B2 oh it's
check wait that's me trying to check me
too hard no no oh my gosh and did he
just give him the wave did he just give
him the Jordan pool bye-bye KN F7 what
is happening king6 kn4 was winning wa
don't give up your Pawn g
d
G3 oh this has been amazing this is the
best game ever best game
ever
[Music]
a
It's the final of the final here at the
I am n GM speed Chess Championship Levy
Rosman AKA Gotham chess is down three
against Paulina sha I'm Robert H
alongside me Kasa Corley Kasa right now
Levy Trails but he did just seize the
momentum based on last game yeah he cut
the deficit to three points and Levy has
a history of coming back from being down
three points in these types of matches
so I think it's there's all to play for
right now and we're going to get one of
the most exciting segments probably will
ever see and we have had plenty of
exciting action in IM sec's pass Levy
Rosen played a part in the one in 2021
you see our past champions John
Bartholomew he beat Alina keslin Roberto
Molina beat Levy Rosman and Eric Rosen
last year beat James KY so no matter who
wins today we will have our youngest
Champion yet yeah and it's crazy because
you know you basically play chess all
your life in different ways you work on
your openings you work on your end games
you work on your middle games and now
it's basically who is a better Need for
Speed speed throttle here who's going to
read and react better and it's just it's
just such a funny way to end and decide
things but it's the right way and it's
the exciting way for the fans well you
see the players they are getting set and
Paulina she looks Lazer focused and Levy
maybe he's messaging some friends he did
say in a previous interview that he has
received well wishes in between his time
segs maybe he's talking to his friend
and someone who helps him train and Alex
OSI yeah Alex is a well-known guy on the
on the New York City chess scene a good
friend of Levy and uh Hey words of
encouragement could uh could go a long
way in any uh in any chest or any life
situation meanwhile we have Paulina
enshrouded by darkness in the cave ready
to take some prisoners well she wants to
take Levy down to that deep dark Forest
there's only room out for two in the
words of Mikel tall who she said has
been a great inspiration for her own
play and we have what looks to me like a
London system and the POG Champions
they'll be happy to see it but the rest
of the people I'm not sure if we have
too many London fans in the chat and
don't don't be so uh you know confused
by what Levy is doing Lev is trying to
attack he wants to get G4 G5 going I
don't think he's trying to play this
positionally at all and there looks like
there should be some tactics with the
Knight C7 but I don't think this night
E5 can get out of the way soon enough
and Levy is burning plenty of time here
he's out 20 seconds where Paulina she
has as much time as she started with I'm
shocked de castled it's objectively a
very reasonable move but I am surprised
stylistically that he went for it pen is
going to try to trade pieces and nullify
the pressure in the center and the queen
side doubling of Rooks here is is really
dangerous here it comes the second Rook
for black is about to come to C8 and
these deep pawns are very weak for white
so strategically black is cruising but
maybe there's some tactics here Knight
G4 put pressure on the pin PE pce it's
fortunate for black that Knight can come
to D7 to help defend although there
might be Knight takes D5 know Knight
takes D5 Knight takes D5 the Bish on D6
is overloaded oh and it's missed okay
yeah that's one of those tactics that
you just miss because the pawn protects
the Knight protects but the bishop was
overloaded the queen and the Rook yeah
now everything is protected for pina and
I think she's just going to seek out
some trades and maintain the time
Vantage 20 minutes up on the clock right
now this is horrible for Levy because
Knight takes Queen takes the D4 Pawn is
loose this bishop on D6 is a monster so
he brings his Knight into E5 the engine
does not approve this is getting out of
hand I like 95 from a practical
perspective trying to keep some piece on
the board trying to keep those Knights
on the board we know how tricky they are
on bullet penia is going to seek out
trades uh Queen B7 Queen C7 I think
those types of moves make a lot of sense
and what an excellent move Queen C7 is
forcing the Queens off the Knight is
hanging 7 seconds for Levy he trade the
Queens he has to go maybe Knight D7 here
otherwise his Knight could be trapped is
that Knight where's that Knight going
after Knight takes D7 Knight D7 all of a
sudden this King maybe can get in the
game although the Knight starts to
Chisel away at some pawns this is not as
simple as it looks and uh Pina she's
taking more time okay Knight C5 push the
pawn to A5 defend the a pawn get your
king to the center King f8 King E7 yeah
bring that King in and there might be
Bishop takes C5 at some moment so you
need to be very careful if you're Levy
especially if black can push D4 as well
that pawn may be stranded oh that is a
excellent observation and something she
she definitely should look out for
although G4 closing the position for
that Bishop I would have kept it open H5
basically just trying to cement things
keep that Bishop keep that Bishop on the
uhoh bishop E1 at the right moment with
H4 this is going to hurt that Knight is
almost
trapped and now it is trapped Knight A6
Bishop D6 and King B6 to follow but he
gets B4 it oh you had to start with I
think Bishop C3 was the better Square
because then the then you could actually
play B4 without losing the pawn oh and I
don't know if she can win this anymore
because the King on E3 isn't perfect
location F6 played she takes it she
wants E5 all right this is going to be a
draw folks because both sides are going
to have protected passers and the other
side cannot you know move their King
away from it so this is going to be a
repetition in short order unless there
any Mouse slips and if D4 is played
Black has to play E4 the draw is by
repetition and that means the
three-point lead still exists we have
team scandy John Bartholomew the
champion of 2020 he'll be proud what do
you make of this opening decision by
Levy yeah as Lil Wayne used to say this
is the remix baby because basically
Knight F6 is not your traditional scandy
you you normally play Queen takes D5 so
this is
different hey it's different I love that
we just got a little Wayne reference
next I guess we got to talk about Skip
bis and their friendship but that's for
another show the bishop does go out to
F4 Kasa this looks like white has
Pleasant play thus far but the shell of
Black's position is very strong yeah
yeah the shell as you're describing it
is perfectly legit um the Rooks are
connected for white though I think it's
about equal although the C2 Pawn might
be a little loose and that's why D5 is
played I think this is something that
Levy might be able to take advantage of
now that E5 Pawn might be a Target later
and Knight E4 no que tak5 there's Knight
D6 so she is tactically alert oh and he
walks into it Knight D6
are you sack the queen it's not over
this is a this is a bullet it's not over
coordinate those Rooks get your Rook to
D2 and game on it is not over the game
is certainly on the bishop on G6 is such
a Powerhouse defending both pawns and
threatening the C2 Pawn so this is
chances for Levy he didn't seem that
flustered by his blunder and he has
every bit of an opportunity to stay in
this game and now the Rooks even have
the opportunity to double on the second
rank this is actually practically
speaking probably a little bit easier to
play um as black cuz your moves are at
least there's isn't any question about
what you do although now that the lines
are opened I changed my mind the queen
now is going to
Menace the queen is going to start to
Menace let that King be exposed like
this was not the right decision and good
move by Levy to play H at some point
though Kasa G4 will be an option for
white to Spring free a pass Pawn Yeah
and I just it's going to be hard to
cover this King on B7 indefinitely as
the clock gets lower um Le's got to hold
on to this A4 Pawn with all all his
might okay so we're seeing here that the
black king is sheltered by the Rooks and
the pawns and queen D7 check is only a
single check this Rook needs to get to a
sore like B2 oh C3 that should help oh
Rook C5 Queen D4
pins oh my gosh this is so unpleasant to
play practically I queen D4 Queen C4
Queen takes C6 it looks like that's
going to be the pattern
oo oh she wants now the king now the
king can go to A6 the king of shelter
now all of a
sudden it's still not perfectly safe but
after A3 Rook takes A3 with Queen A6 to
follow and she finds it and again this
position is not lost in my estimation
basically the C Pawn is still going to
be a factor my question now is how many
how much of the match clock will be off
after this game because it feels like
there are a lot of checks to be had here
we still have 18 plus minutes on the
match clock and this is a game where
both sides have chances to win black has
a pass Pawn but with paulina's decision
on the king side if she can kick this
bishop out here her Pawn can run up I
wouldn't repeat put the queen on C3 and
keep the clock going they're going to
repeat but I think if you play Queen C3
uh you can kind of you know waste more
time as we've seen in previous matches
Levy might be trying to win this but I'm
not sure his King can really Escape
Queen h8 over here this bishop under H5
H5 oh my God he takes wait a second but
F7 is Hing no no no and then miss she
misses it Queen C2 yes now black Ki but
the thing is the queen just stays put
but you can't really win this position I
don't think no but I'm thinking about
clock oh my gosh F4 with Queen d8 to
follow oh my God that would have been a
fork that won the game Levy is taking
too many risks
here he's looking at pina's clock and
and and that's why he's doing it but
yeah okay there's no way to blockade now
there's no check now you got to get back
to
C1 okay the the good news for black is
white is Frozen the bad news for black
there's no way to kick the queen out of
here and so this game well do not take
on C2 what is this King on E3 doing yeah
stay where you are do not do anything uh
don't not do anything any anything rash
because then and do not take on C2
because the king p in games are lost
well when the Rook went to the D file on
D4 the whiteing could have gone a C3 so
both sides are playing on seconds oh
actually Levy has nearly 20 but he's
playing as if he's got two yeah and I
mean the funny thing is you could say
Levy is making some progress but really
there's just no way to really improve
this one so I would I would go to next
game Queen D2 there's King C4 so she
goes King D2 instead what what wait this
is
kick that was a kick winning kick Point
again game oh my goodness and Levy
misses it and now it's going to be a
draw once
again neither side Pina should not be
pre-moving here I would not pre-move
right now in that situation
man wow that game lasted 102 moves Took
a ton of time off the match clock both
sides had their chances and Paulina she
survives she gets that half point and
now Levy he needs to start winning
because he remains down by three with 16
minutes to go I need to like breathe
after that but there's no time
okay Pina Pina is playing a little bit
of a bishop B5 check is really nice for
white white has the center white has
active pieces white is mauling right now
Bishop A4 keep the keep the pin on D7 oh
and Levy takes it he thinks that his
position is good enough and well it
should be he is up a pawn and the black
king I think it has to go to C6 but it's
almost checkmated yeah castling with
Czech is always aesthetically pleasing I
can't blame Levy for going for this um
still black is the two Bishops it's a
bullet game um it's there's still work
to be done and Pina is a very good
Defender as we've seen in previous uh
games it's not easy to crash through and
E5 is played maybe it's a little bit too
soon you're not threatening Pawn takes
F6 if this bishop takes back that's a
strong dark Square Bishop so Levy
clearly in charge right now but Paulina
is showing that she may bend in some
positions but she's not going to break
that B5 that B5 square is now super
available like and
now the Knight comes to D6 at some point
yeah E5 is hanging so he switches his
Knights to force the king to the last
rank yeah and that now the Rooks aren't
connected this this Rook on a is in jail
um yeah there's a lot to like about
white position Levy is doing ex
everything exceptionally well right now
and I think you just moov the Knight
away from D4 then the Rooks can come in
or how about C6 Robert C6 if Pawn takes
Knight takes C6 right now too that
should still be
available okay that's also good Rook
takes F6 you could take with the Knight
and protect the Rook on D1 and if you
didn't have Knight takes back then you
would have lost your piece so what's the
material count it's only one extra Pawn
for white but it should be enough with a
knight invading up to D6 but this Rook
wants to slide to E2 yeah I mean you you
could basically give that check and then
go King C8 but uh you got to like white
here white is although the trade of
pawns will definitely help black if you
can get to some type of end game with
the pawns on the same side two verse one
you'd have some chances to hold but this
king is now getting super active and now
once the pawn gets to B6 all the mating
patterns are there and Levy's time
management has been incredible he has
nearly 40 seconds this late in the game
he does allow the king up to C6 there's
no good Discovery for this Knight I'm
actually a little bit concerned by that
decision as the C5 Pawn will be tender
yeah Rook B4 check will come play now
and the King might have to be nudged
away letting the king out of the box is
a little surprising and Knight D6 or
King to be oh King before this goes
right back into a checkmating there yeah
and very very well spotted although this
bishop 1 G2 is clocking overtime
guarding the B7 Pawn staying on the
diagonal and all of a sudden there might
be some counterplay Rook H4 check C5 is
about to drop but she instead walks the
white king forward I don't know about
that yeah this
we technique could be forgiven given the
control pina's got to move way faster
down to two seconds here she wants
Bishop E4 if she can steal that pawn
with her Bishop Bishop E4 bishop4 Rook
H2 Bishop E4 is coming anyway she was
worried about Bishop E4 basically that's
why she played Rook
H2 and now it's not winning anymore
Bishop's comeing to C2 God oh my God
what defense Rook takes H7 take the pawn
yeah she's going to take this pawn and
now it should be a draw should being the
operative word in time trouble black may
lose this Knights are very tricky pieces
and how long does levy try to win this
game does he oh
discovery4
977 forks and Paulina should not resign
she should play this out waste another
10 seconds on the match talk or more if
she can and just play the
Checkmate oh my goodness oh my
goodness this is shortening my lifespan
man oh it's shortening the the players
lifespan as well as Levy takes that game
it is now 9 and 1 half to 7 and A2 so
for Paulina she needs to stem it she
needs to stop this because Levy is
gaining in confidence yeah and it's a
two-point deficit with 11 minutes to go
and everything to play for and we got
this this uh this remix Scandinavian
again and uh I think POA is handling it
a lot better than the first time this
looks fantastic for white you have great
control in the center because your pawns
are connected how many times cost have
We Said Today when this Pawn was on C2
the D4 Pawn was stranded now those pawns
are with each other probably too many
but now folks get the picture so there
you go but uh I do not like that pieace
trade one of the things you'll you could
say about Pina she will go for trades or
consolidations when they're not needed
that peace trade on E5 helped black
breathe when you lack space you want to
keep minor you want to trade minor
pieces when you have space you don't
want to do the same because black is
struggling to get ground and so you're
giving black some breathing life and we
see Rook takes D7 might be a new threat
that's with the King went H2 off the
diagonal and A7 is hanging here this
queen is not going to get trapped grab
that
pawn that's Everything Must Go sale you
just got to collect that and come back
and then you could double the Rooks on
the defile if you want at a later Jun
sure that D6 square is
Outpost um C5 giving the Knight the D5
Square not my first choice now it's
actually not so clear but she has Queen
B6 that's why she did it to get the
Knight out of there and now in this
position it looks like the black Rook is
about to come up the board and go for
but is there F5 and Bishop E2 ooh ooh
that would have been that's a tough spot
but that was beautiful tactic F5 bish2
would have won material this version now
is going to give Le the best he could
have possibly imagined getting into this
end game because B6 will be picked off
and uh yeah there's all to play for I
don't even know who's better anymore
this King might run up to F4 but wait a
second E5 is immediately loose if Pina
can get E6 in she's very happy but
that's a ways
away the Aon is a target this is
Advantage Levy Advantage Levy the a paon
is dropping off this E7 check E7 check
and and then G5 and F6 oh my
God yeah you just get a pass Pawn that's
connected deep in enemy
territory all right now the end games
are winning these Rook end games there
just too many pawns that are dropping B4
is is weak as well you can even start
with Rook A4 basically or Rook B3 is a
better version of that this is a winning
well King
E7 King D6 is this she want she wants
something like this the engines didn't
like it at first but now after Rook B3
which was the most natural move here
comes the Rook oh my goodness checking
back checking back to
E7 can you go and then is rookie six
check again I would play that G6 might
lose to
F6 I mean it' take real bravery to play
uh to play G6 there and Levy brings his
King all the way back to the final rank
he is up two pawns he wants to win this
game desperately wants to win to cut the
deficit in half you got to push your
pawn and go G5 here right and that
forces a trade a Rooks What a fine by
but also great response by P keeping the
Rooks on because Rook takes E7 Pawn
takes in the pawn promotes so now she
steals the H7 Pawn but too many extra
pawns for black yeah and and it's just
too far down the board and another Rook
trade excellent excellent find and Levy
he is riled up he is very happy about
what's happened because it was down by
three now it's down by one and Paulina
she's struggling here in the bullet yeah
and again she's getting down on the
clock too those scrambles Levy was up on
the clock and and she just can't have
that if she wants to win and we see Levy
going back to this F3 system in the what
is they call the verosol it's kind of
like um the fantasy variation of the
kakan and this doesn't look very
pleasant for white because the D4 Pawn
is probably loose here E5 wow that is
aggressive as heck man all right so e
takes D4 I guess you need to play right
because if C takes D5 you have uh you
have some Bishop B5 check stuff so
taking on D4 all if you take on G6 you
fix Black's Pawn structure and then the
F7 Square becomes available to the black
king in case of any
checks okay and so Knight E2 play didn't
want to see that Knight captured on C3
Queen takes D5 I think that looks very
strong Bishop B4 check can hardly blame
her for throwing in the check now take
this Pawn on how do you feel about
Knight F4 though it is an annoying move
to face you hit the queen you asked that
you hit G6 you asked some questions
Queen trade I am shocked I thought that
the technical phase is where Paulina is
stronger but this is bullet you don't
have all the time in the world to
consolidate and Levy has shown a
propensity with the Knights to get some
tricky Forks in and Levy doesn't have
all the time in the world to mount this
comeback it's six and a half minutes
remaining in the match so I'm keeping an
eye on that because Kasa this is better
for black I think both players recognize
at this stage it's not losing but at
some moment now it's looking Clos loss
KN C4 happens Levy might consider
hitting the resign
button yeah that is a oh F4 Knight G4
there's too many targets here but wait
Rook d8 get the Rook get the Rook to d8
threaten
Checkmate uhoh L's turning this around
once again and the Knights he is
maneuvering really well at the Knights
this Rook is going to come to H3 and
revive itself that way uh although five
and King C6 and Rook d1s mate it threats
Checkmate oh my gosh that Rook up B7 for
the second time today is trapped in a
wrong place although you can can you try
Knight C2 and Knight E1 I don't believe
in it but I think that's what you try
right oh my goodness so Rook moves Rook
D1 check Knight E1 and there's still
work to be done here if if you're black
I think the natural move would be to
just double your Rooks but this is not
over yet no apparently not the Knight
comes to C3 to block the dag and The
Rook it saves the Knight on E1 as well
oh this has turned to again this is this
is Turing again
Robert oh my goodness what a game this
has been Rook D6 off why would you trade
Rooks you're attacking you do not attack
when you're all right this is this is
totally changed this is now chances for
white yes Knight D3 hits the C5 Pawn she
goes back she very
smartly do oh she could have traded
Knights she should have traded Knights
now she's losing a pawn yeah if you
trade Knights and then gone F5 it would
have been a dead drawn King Pawn end
game now this a winning King Pawn
anything for white oh my goodness Levy
Rosman out of nowhere Knight C4 Knight
E5 check it's over the H you can even
play Robert you can even play Knight
takes G6 and H5 as a P sacrifice in some
lines because the knights suck guarding
H pawns right but uh we're not going to
need that C5 dropped but so does C4 so
it's two extra pawns for Levy this
should be very manageable unless he
blunders one of those pawns yeah I I'm
not going to speak too soon but we are
very very close close very close to
getting a tied match oh my goodness for
Paulina she was on the offensive and now
her Knight is trapped I thought that
King could have walked over to trap the
Knight but still this is good enough
because now the king moves up and will
help
out oh my
goodness we are tied with little less
than four minutes left we are tied he is
a bullet brawler he keeps coming back in
the final section of these matches it's
a tied match and Paulina now has the
white pieces Levy he's playing in the
style of the Kings Indian what do you
think Paulina has to do first of all
Paulina played D4 I don't know if she's
P thus far in this match is that a tilt
decision because she was pretty much
playing E4 throughout and now she's just
like I've had enough of this what do you
make of that I think that she has had
enough she wants to change the scenery
because hasn't been working out well for
her and I'm looking at the match clock 3
minutes and about to be 15 seconds
remaining so both players better keep an
eye on that clock cuz you're losing you
resigned I'm just Kasa the overall match
clock will play a huge role in this
specific game she's thinking a long time
here because this is not a position
she's played a much to date in this
match and again that was that's one of
the other things is she was used to
those other positions she played them a
little bit faster this is different
she's down 10 seconds and
I don't know how much you know the eval
really matters here well white has a
healthy position it's very Kings Indian
style C5 is what you want to accomplish
but Levy he is keeping control over the
key squares on the queen C but Knight B3
C5 these smooth team quite natural and
Knight F1 and Bishop H6 so why did that
Knight go backwards yeah I think Knight
F3 was definitely the the Preferred
Choice oh there was eight takes before
tactic cuz the Rook was unprotected for
a move and Levy might be a little bit
too quickly and Paulina she strikes at
the right moment with C5 please take me
twice shatter your own Pawn structure
she says because E5 and C5 they probably
will not hang around too long I think
the the the clock time is more important
than the position here though uh Robert
I I feel that in my bones like uh this
clock time is the most important factor
and Pina has to adjust before she uh
before she you know the similar things
happen essentially well Levy I don't
know if it was a sacrifice or for an
accident he gave up the H5 pawn and so
paulina's up a pawn but her King is In
Harm's Way the queen May slide to G3
just to save her king and the Knight is
in the well is well position here to
defend it Queen E3 that's actually a
really nice move and then after the
queen moves you might even nestl to F4
because I don't think trades are are
useful here why would you trade that I
thought that trades would help Pina I
think Lev's aiming for end games where
White's pawns are in some danger here
Bishop B5 is going to hurt
yeah and then the D6 Pawn might be a
Target the F5 Pawn is a target nice
decision not to trade though and Rook G8
keeping the Knight on E2 stuck for the
moment but Knight D4 is coming Rook F1
as well I think that pawn on F5 is in
huge
trouble yeah Knight to F4 this Rook this
Rook could come to C1 and Target the
bishop on
C8 uh the timing not ideal but I still
think it makes sense and hold on there
are some tricks with Rook B2 and Knight
F3 check um but maybe White first
knight6 knight3 check you called it and
it's available and Rook takes D5 was
played instead so both players
overlooking tactics here Kasa suddenly
black is up a pawn Knight f8 to threaten
m one well don't hang your Rook but
Knight f8 check wait the rook's
hanging oh my gosh look at these Knights
though these knights in the center what
if we have D5 D4 shortly okay so how do
you stop the pass pawns big question
Levy is going all In For the Win right
now but the H Pawn could be dangerous
Knight D5 one up Pawn Knight D5 Knight
takes F4 what a pawn oh my gosh missed
by both players The Rook slides back to
A1 if Pawn to F2 King can slide to G2
just in time just pushed the H Pawn H5
H6 Knight G4 wins the pawn again Knight
takes F2 oh and that's a great move to
throw because now the knights are stuck
with each other and now trades are
happening and the H Pawn will win the
the game and then Rook A3 you pin and
you sack and then you push the H Pawn
you're in time this Pawn is too slow
white wins the game and it's the last
game of the match it's the last game
game of the match time is
up oh my goodness so Paulina is going to
win don't pre-move no need to pre-move
here oh my
goodness and Levy just notices and
Paulina sha leans back she puts her
hands in the air like she just don't
care she has won the
imcc oh my goodness oh my goodness I
lost track of the match clock there my
goodness
wow there are no words Casa for what
Paulina just did she was the one who was
struggling in the bullet and yet in that
last game where nerves were on the line
there was chaos on the board she wins it
yeah and again super clutch I mean this
is not the first time she's been in this
situation where she needs to win on
Demand with the in the last round of the
last game of the one plus one this time
it wasn't on demand but she treated it
as such and she got a huge huge clutch W
cannot believe what we just witnessed
that went down to the very last game but
when all is said and done Paulina Shala
wins the match 10 and a half n and half
bullet which was Levy rosman's best
friend in the entire IMC that last game
it just didn't go his way this went
pretty much how we predicted the 5 plus
one was in pina's favor the three plus
one got a little more interesting and
then the one plus one Levy stormed back
with Incredible force and Pina was did
just enough to hold him off and become
our winner in
2023 of I am not a GM SEC it might also
be her last time being available cuz she
can't she's the champion but she might
become a Grandmaster chat ask your
questions for Paulina we're going to
bring her in for an interview we would
love to feature some of them so we'll be
right back and joined by your IMC
Champion Paulina Shala we'll be right
[Music]
back
Jack that is it still plenty of options
and opportunities left all right next
one you ready yes
Let There kasparian study
white okay I know this ah you know it
it's not fair que A3 Rook D Rook D2 Rook
B2 very kasparian kasparian study yes
looks kind of
familiar
but okay yeah Rook D2 Rook B2
rook1 so how do you start Queen A3 Rook
A2 Rook D2
Rook takes A3 Rook B2 Rook A2 Rook B one
very nice very nice well done okay so
it's Queen A3 check Rook A2 then Rook B2
Rook A3 Rook B2 Rook A3 Rook B1 very
nice yeah very nice
yes impressive knowledge another study I
mean if you know this one I'll be
mightly impressed why to move okay this
one I don't know
so it's 10 seconds as well 10 seconds
oh um yeah Bishop B6 C5 que B8 B6 C8
King C8 King E4 H4 H4
um now I have to yes King F5 and H5 and
King E4 yeah very nice is King E4 the
final move Bishop B6 Queen B 6 C5 Queen
B8 B6 King C8 King E4 yes H4 and King F5
H5 King E4 King E4 back yeah very nice
well done okay this one is a bit
difficult I say so I guess we should Tak
B6 yes Queen B6 C5 yes Queen B8 B6 mhm
Queen C8 mhm
C7 Queen
B7 uh C7 might not be correct
oh oh King E4 King E4 yes yes yes H4
H4 you have a Pawn on G3 H4 and H6 right
yes okay then King F5 K H4 exactly yeah
very nice that's the one very nice
yeah okay if I lose a game before I go
to sleep I have to play until I win
and once I win a game then I will play
another why isn't my chess rating going
[Music]
up
w
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
a massive congratulations are in order
for Paulina Shala who just took down
Levy Rosman in what was a nailbiter so
Paulina we have to applaud you how are
you feeling right now and how did you do
that
oh well I'm feeling I'm feeling pretty
exhausted um but overall I'm I'm happy
of course
and um as usual um I made it to the to
the intrig and to the last
game uh so yeah it was um a really good
match uh interesting in terms of um I
felt like I was uh dominating in the
slow controls uh but
uh probably I did not make too too much
merch uh so that um Levy is a very good
um bullet
player as I see now uh after the match
he's like almost 29 in bullets so it's
it's like much more rating than I have
in bullet so it is no surprise that
he uh
like made it um back to the eal match
again in bullet um but uh yeah I'm very
happy that in the last game I uh I
managed to complete myself together and
and
win poina let's actually talk about that
last game because there were so many
twists and turns along the way and I
guess one of the first things to even
mention is you switched to D4 you were
playing e before most the match and then
it felt like in the bullet phase
something changed and you were losing
some momentum but you ended the match
with D4 was that a conscious choice to
just switch it up or what what led it
what led you down that
path uh during the game I I started to
think that it was like the worst choice
I made in whole match as um this
structure that I played I thought that
he will play it some moment E4 and just
go straight for the mate
and usually white is playing on the
queen side here and black is going for
the mate so in bullet section it was uh
really easy to to be just attacked and
um like without any
fight uh but he he went for this King
indan he allowed me to play D5 and D4
and
it um it got just very unbalanced and uh
for sure we made like a million blunders
in this
game uh
yeah well of course blunders and
brilliancies are going to happen in
these matches and Paulina did you do you
think you felt any extra nerves knowing
that many people were watching and in
fact at different points over 30,000
people were watching at any given moment
so lots of eyes were on your
match
oh that's great 30 something is
great but I I didn't know about it uh
honestly
so uh no I was just uh I was just uh
concentrated um on my games uh because
if you like start to think how many
peoples are watching your game and all
your like blanders and and King the
queen as uh as I found out in match with
the Lawrence strent we had that last
game in the like main segment before the
ti break uh in which uh Queen on E1 was
hanging like four or five moves straight
so it was just just
crazy and yeah I'm I mean um I'm just um
I'm just playing try try to play my
best
what were your expectations going into
the event and then going into this match
in particular were you uh did what were
you what was your thought process going
into
it uh my expectations about the
tournament um and and before the
tournament ends in like a um how to say
it preliminary stage the stage where for
people were playing so I I thought that
like going into the furthest St stage is
uh an incredible success
so uh well before all the matches I
played on
chesc uh I mean
this these official tournament official
matches they were going really tough for
me and uh the previous year of uh I am
not GM also went pretty tough uh from
the start so I was
just uh just enjoying going into every
stage and
um yeah I think we had um an amazing
final so overall it's uh it's pretty
good yeah it definitely was an amazing
final and one that you started off on a
hot streak so Paulina did you have
nerves this is a question from the chat
from scobby dog saying you know given
the great start that you had were there
any nerves as Levy started to fight
back uh it was uh I can say not nerves
but uh
disappointments like when I had this um
plus
five uh score and
then and then I like played some some
games and I was again to plus three
going in into bullet section uh and as
everybody says CLE is an amazing bullet
player so I I already thought I
understood that plus three is um like
nothing for the bullet section for the
uh 25 minutes we had so it's like um
still a very tough and almost equal
match and as it as it shows
up
another uh feature chat question or
another chat question here from Krishna
21234 what time of day is it for you
right now and how do you plan on
celebrating
this uh it's uh it's like 13 minutes
after midnight for
me
so uh not not much of celebration today
uh maybe tomorrow I don't
know well yeah it is clearly dark there
by you and you should be able to
celebrate and we have another question
from zenam asking you what are your
plans going
forward um I I will play in the AIS of
man in like um 5 days so this is the
main
event uh and after this um I'm not sure
probably maybe the the next tournament
will be just um Bliss and Rapid
championship in the end of the
year awesome and I guess there was
something that we noticed very early on
there were just so many carolans
between you and and Levy just duking out
the on the kacan did you notice that
during the match and was their intention
like yeah I like these positions or I
want to keep playing
them well um I I played kakan uh almost
um in every game during this event so it
was like my my main opening um but I
felt that Levy was getting trickier
during the match he started to play this
stuff with the F3 with the like Knight
um D4 Knight C3 this bishop G5 so he he
was trying to like beat me in some sharp
and tactical
positions um so
yeah if I remember correctly it it was
him who turned to to more of T4
stuff but carakan is quite you know a
solid
opening uh it should not be losing
straight and uh in one game we played um
I'm not sure um you can ask Levy
probably after this he played this stuff
with the in karakan third Knight C3
takes Knight F6 takes
like then Bishop D3 C3 he played this
line with Bishop F4 Queen
D2 like was he watching the game of uh
of paravan uh paravan
against against kukesh where David just
made a brilliant sacrifice on G6 or was
SL just randomly playing that it was
interesting but yeah we're we're just um
you know we're playing this high level
stuff in our tournament so it's pretty
good it wasn't just pretty good it was
fantastic and you Paulina we appreciate
you answering all these questions and my
my final question for you is you know
what are your final thoughts of the
tournament and what Reflections do you
have after getting through the group
stage and now all the way to winning the
title I'm very happy very happy happy to
win this
title um and um I really like the uh the
forat I think it's sort of new format
for this events uh for this early stage
that we're
playing uh we're playing like three mini
matches um with double
elimination so I think it's pretty good
and um yeah overall it's it was it was
interesting to play and uh I played with
some uh charismatic and um and were
famous uh in ch world people so I
enjoyed it and um yeah I hope uh I hope
them also enjoyed it and viewers
also the viewers definitely enjoyed it
you have so many fans out there who are
rooting you on during this match I'm
sure we might see some Gotham chess
videos with your name on them as well
but Paulina we know it's late in the
night time for you so we'll let you go
but congratulations once again you are
the IMC Champion so you should be very
proud thank
you Paul PA Paulina is our champion she
had so many great thoughts on the event
that was and we are also going to get
Levy rosman's thoughts so please give us
some questions for Gotham chess we know
you'll have many he'll be joining us
just after this break so stay tuned we
are going to bring on The Internet's
number one chess teacher in just a
[Music]
few
[Applause]
[Music]
what
Jack
it
[Music]
out what
what
[Music]
jacket it
out
[Music]
Jack
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah there are there are a few I mean
one for sure is interviewing
the Holocaust Survivor in 1956 French
women's chess champion Isabelle shoko
started out as a podcast for ladies
night in the grid and it turned out that
I got a chance to travel to Paris and
actually meet Isabelle herself that's a
little piece that's going to be coming
out in chess.com soon that was just
magical I mean I'm Jewish and you know
seeing the rise of anti-Semitism is is
really disturbing and to be able to talk
to somebody who was almost slaughtered
in one of the worst atrocities of all
time but is still living 80 years later
and really not just living but thriving
like providing so much inspiration to
everyone around the world I mean it's a
magical Moment Like This is like one of
the reasons why we play chass and why we
create art for moments like that so I
feel uh really lucky to have met
Isabelle and thankful for that also
another moment that really stands out
for me was when UD pogar uh visited my
us chess girls Pub we had hundreds of
girls there from all over the world in
fact we had girls from Kenya we had
girls from you know obviously the United
States from
Colombia and we also had adult women
there as well um so it was a huge
turnout and udit was just so charming
and Brilliant in her answers and
particularly I noticed that a lot of
girls asked her similar questions on a
variation of like what do you do if your
confidence is shattered what do you do
if you lose a few games in a row if
you're scared if you don't know what to
do and it's funny because unit's like
reply was so striking to me because she
was just like oh man this these
questions are tough for me because I've
always been so
confident and uh she did manage to reply
but it was interesting to me to see that
that was a bit of a struggle for her
because she has always had that
confidence that she was great
she hasn't suffered from imposter
syndrome and I think that's a big secret
to her success and just a reminder of
how important confidence is to becoming
um the best chess player that you can
[Music]
be
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
he
[Music]
and we are thankful to be joined by The
Internet's number one chess teacher Levy
Rosman Levy sorry the match didn't go
your way how are you feeling right now
what are your
[Music]
thoughts uh I feel I don't I don't feel
that bad
um I think it's pretty well known at
this point like when I when when I play
these matches or any serious events uh I
tend to get pretty stressed uh I was
pretty stressed today again um she was
playing like unbelievably well uh in
5-1 and in 3-1 and when she went out
five I just sort of laughed and I was
like
well that's
it like I'm gonna just do my best you
know at that when you're down Five
Points it's like well I'm you know
there's like that that thing you know
nobody beats my basketball team by 50
points kind of a thing you know like I'm
a Knicks fan so I was like well I'm you
know I'll just keep it close I guess um
and then when I got some momentum in the
bullet I I was like wow there's a actual
chance I might win the match um and when
I finally realized I was losing this
crazy last game I looked at the game
clock and there was two seconds and I
was not fast enough to like resign and
start the new game so just happy to have
made it exciting at the end and you know
not uh not have lost by like 10 points
Levy it felt in the at the end of the 3+
one segment you just got a really clutch
win to break basically bring it to a
three-point deficit and then it felt
like game on especially because we've
seen your history of mounting incredible
bullet comebacks and segments did you
feel that way going into the OnePlus One
cuz it felt like that 3 plus one was
just an incredible uh incredible
close yeah yeah I think what made that
last 3-1 game even better um was the
fact that she was winning for a move
like I saw it you know I didn't see a
huge amount of tactics uh this match but
I saw that one uh where she had the Rook
lined up on my night and queen and I
made my move and I went oh Rook D7 and I
just like that's it I mean I'm going to
be down whatever four going into bullet
and then she didn't play it and then two
moves later she blundered Queen B4 and
so I think yeah like going all the way
down all the way up definitely helped uh
but I didn't start the bullet well I
mean there was that one crazy game then
I like was I mean she hung a Pawn on E5
I thought and then I hung my queen that
was pretty cool I straight up didn't see
it like that wasn't even deliberate um
so it was definitely kind of nice to to
win that game uh and I I unfortunately
wasn't able to like fully capitalize on
the momentum
until the the last four bullet
games
and Levy you two were playing a theme
match kakan was played quite a lot and
actually Paulina had a question for you
when we asked her about some of the
openings she was wondering if you had
seen that paravian GES game since you
followed that
line yes 100% uh it's funny that uh that
she even like called it out in the
interview I saw she played
caroan and I didn't really know what to
play I just saw she played the tarow so
I was like well I'm going to try a bit
of everything and just sort of see what
works um and I I tried that but it was a
common theme in the five minute and the
three minute that she was playing moves
so fast in the opening that I was like
is she just bluffing really well or is
she prepared in all of these lines and
when you are playing 5 minute and 1
second bonus you have a tendency to just
like sit there and start thinking as if
if it's you know classical or rapid
chess um so that was actually very
distressing it was kind of nice later in
the match when I started playing some
veras sovs and modern you know G6 D6 A6
with black that she was actually taking
a lot of time in the opening because
that that that was nice for a
change yeah it definitely felt like
throughout that match there was this tug
of war where Paulina wanted to play
technical positions and consolidate and
you were just trying to fiercely attack
and then the clock came into play a ton
as well where it felt like if you were
up on time going into a scramble
Advantage Levy and if she had like a
minute or 50 seconds in a good position
going into you know a a transition or a
consolidation phase Advantage pulina did
you feel those Contours as well or was
it
different it's really hard to identify
uh exactly what is happening
during the games at least for me maybe
some maybe some people are better at
that uh when these games are happening
I'm just like all right um you know
don't fall behind a certain amount of
time I thought I thought I ended up
doing that a little bit better in the
three minute segment so I think um I was
down time less often and I was actually
up time quite a bit um so yeah I mean
nothing specific
but uh yeah of course like once you're
down four games you you can or five
games you can play solidly or you can
just kind of try to go out in your sword
so uh I'm not you know I'm not really
going to change my playing style at that
point and it was paying off in some of
those positions and uh I could tell like
you know toward the last two three games
you know she was it's probably a mix of
everything a little bit of
disappointment a little bit of like
frustration tilt uh I could sense from
her moves and the pace and everything
that uh I was maybe taking over the mat
but I never even got a chance to lead
right because it all came down to this
one game um yeah that's probably how I
would describe
it well that makes a lot of sense Levy
and we did ask the chat for some
questions and we have one here for you
from we weams asking are you entering
the IMA GM Championship next
year
um I I mean probably I I don't know I
don't really know what else I have to do
um but uh yeah these things like every
single time I play them they get me more
and more stressed out and um I don't
really enjoy them until they're over
it's uh it's weird and I I'm like very
open about this and the same with
classical chess I just get so so
stressed uh there are like frequently
moments during these three hours that
I'm just staring at the screen
and like nothing is happening I'm just
looking at my little Monitor and then I
make some move and now I'm down you know
90 seconds on the clock and I and I'm in
a worse position so I think the relief I
feel when these matches are over win or
lose is
um uh is is nice but uh it's it's very
stressful for me but I mean I I'll
probably play I mean I I don't take
these like too seriously but I would
have of course been very very happy to
win that last
game yeah we definitely love to see you
in future editions I'm going to ask one
more uh question from arban Paul um you
mentioned previous uh in the previous
match that you kind of just went into it
a bit more casually did you PR prepare
anything for this one uh just given the
the level of opponent that uh uh pulina
basically proved to be in the previous
matches no nothing nothing special I
didn't I mean I just like look at
people's openings um I knew Pina was an
E4 player and she had like a very
strange repertoire where she would take
the pawn on D5 if you played the French
or the
caroan and so I just thought okay like
that's kind of boring and annoying so
you know uh we'll see how it goes and it
did not go well and also she had a lot
of success in the advanced carocon so
then I just decided like I don't know
I'll play like G6 or whatever um but uh
no I tried I tried not to overthink it
because I was like well one of two
things is going to happen I'm either
going to somehow overcome my nerves and
it's going to be a back and fourth match
and the openings don't really matter or
I'm going to just like be down you know
five games and that's kind of what
happened uh and then in the bullet
there's really no point preparing it's
just uh every man or woman or child for
themselves well it did come down to the
wire there Levy and of course you know
we're sorry I didn't go your way but do
you have any thoughts I know it's fresh
but any thoughts or Reflections about
the event the change in format and how
are you feeling uh with everything that
just
transpired uh it was cool um they didn't
really promote the event like at all um
but uh you know uh that I guess it's for
a good reason because if you know games
are of such a quality but they should
have promoted Pina they shouldn't have
promoted me but they should have
promoted you know Pina and and Danny and
Lawrence and Greg and uh all I think all
the other group winners uh the the early
knockout uh stage was um was pretty
interesting and uh these events are you
know they're just they're fun events
and
I'm happy that I played I was hope
hoping to win but I'm
not like I I don't think I have the uh
permission from the chess Gods to be
that upset that I lost it's not like I
was some sort of um you know favorite or
or anything and Pina is a very very good
player and she has a GM Norm I think
she's 2500 fet so you know uh this will
just be a winning this event is
definitely like a like a gym IM in
people's chess careers but hopefully
like Molina who I lost to Paulina you
know in the final they they they go on
to become GMS and then I can say like
look you know I lost to some very very
good players so um that's just sort of
how I think about it and I will I was
going to say return to but I'm literally
do it here anyway uh make videos about
tournaments low ELO chess like mine High
ELO chess and uh World Keeps On spinning
so well we're definitely excited to see
uh more content sorry Kasa it sounds
like you wanted to go in there yeah I
was going to say you gave us a show man
like it was super entertaining you
played some really high chess uh in
different parts of the match and I think
you can definitely I it definitely felt
like I was high and
um and uh I really look forward to
seeing you in action again soon um so uh
yeah I'll toss it to Robert but I just
want to say that I there's a reason that
a lot of folks were watching and and
keen on seeing you play because it's
it's really beautiful to see so and uh
you showed you showed a really good
level as well so um I'm not I'm not
gonna not gonna sit here and act like
you were no you were no slatch here
because you weren't so but anyway Robert
take it away I'm venmoing you right now
for that Kasa thank you and I I also
look forward to covering your games uh
and watching them cuz you know Kasa got
those Norms so that GM push for Kasa is
going to be real big I'm looking forward
to it I like watching Kasa succeed too
so wow this is really wholesome I don't
know why I'm here I feel like I'm third
willing this really great friendship
moment here but in all seriousness Levy
you were awesome you had so many fans
watching you your every move and they're
rooting for you and want to see you play
more so please come back keep uh
swinging at it and it was a tough match
in the end but you really did make
everyone
proud wow thanks guys well uh enjoy the
sign off and uh I'll see you next
time we'll see you soon there Levy and
there you see the final bracket Paulina
shuvalova wins 10 and 1 half 9 and2 it
was a nailbiter it came down to the very
last game as did the semi-finals which
headed into tie breaks Kasa what an
event we just witnessed yeah Pina was
incredibly clutch throughout this entire
event and Levy was a really really
worthy opponent but Pina edged him out
just at the end and I think this format
you know as Pina expressed uh as Levy
also expressed it's really exciting you
get close matches and we're treated to
show after show after show I mean we had
two matches go down to tie break in the
semis we had this final go down to the
last second
and um yeah I think it's what makes it
such a fun uh event to you know
commentate and
watch it was all about the entertainment
in this event the IMC but there also was
prize money up for grabs I almost forgot
about it until our producers just told
me to mention it Paulina wins
$5,450 Levy made about $3,500 himself
Lawrence and Greg they were eliminating
the semis made over 1,000 and you see
the tie for fifth there 4 $50 each my
only question cost is do you think Danny
actually gets that money since it's
coming from chess.com that is a great
question and uh I'm going to plead the
fifth well Danny you know he did very
well he actually beat Paulina in their
mini match before losing in tie breaks
so he gave Paulina really all she could
handle then she was able to take down
Lawrence Trent once more in tie brecks
and finally Levy Rosman in the final
game of their match aasa what your
reflections of the
IMC yeah I think there's just a lot of
talent here um it's a really really
entertaining games I really enjoyed the
format um I think uh you know our
competitors did as well in the group
stages it it had a World Cup vibe to get
to the semis and then I think at the end
of the day you're going to continue to
get these matches that get down to the
wire uh across various disciplines and
so you know chess is changing it's not
just about classical chess anymore it's
about showing your skill in various time
controls and this is the perfect event
to do that and I'm so glad that these
content creators these very strong chess
players were able to Showcase their
talents because the Chess World Isn't
just even though it they make up a large
part of it in Magnus and Fabby and
Hikaru but so many of these IMS
contribute to the game in ways that we
can't even express our gratitude for so
I just want to thank all the competitors
for partic ipating whether they were
winning zero matches or making it all
the way to the final and becoming the
champion so thank you to you all thank
you to everybody who watch you make this
event even more special and
congratulations are in order once more
for pina shalva she earned herself a
title Levy he was also close hopefully
he gets there next time and we will see
you next time for more events on
chess.com we saw this against kristofh
zi Levy playing the same very dubious
opening but these types of openings work
a lot better and Bo
he M he M knowing Levy he's not going to
do it he's going to put the pressure on
and he goes Queen F5 to go Queen H3 it's
main one what did we just witness 83 and
you can hit the button whoa Danny with a
dub this could be difficult for black
you might make a mistake at some point
Rook F4 for example G oh it's winning oh
my God and Danny on time Danny wins give
me the piece it's a free piece oh he's
he's getting it done Danny is getting it
done and Danny is going to four so
wait what a collapse Danny wins four
straight games so it will only be Danny
versus Paulina here we are going all in
they can play check he can play D2 D2 he
lost some time oh my good he lost the
match on time in a we position to
Paulina King h8 the only way to stay in
this game and he finds it and he's
actually winning When the Smoke Clears
it's whites king that's likely to be
caught in a mating net if this Pawn gets
to G3 and right now it can go there but
Levy down to 2 seconds he needs to move
and he puts Rook check first and that oh
made in one
error oh Big Moment 5 seconds for pina
Queen H6 now Rook C7 lorrence still
hanging on by a thread he
takes that was the mistake cuz Rook C8
check is available to White Rook D1
looks like a mate but doesn't work and
now oh it's perpetual what a trick what
a trick Lawrence you cheeky devil Levy
needs a couple more accurate moves
though if you play Rook H2 why would
have taken and stuck a king on up to
Rook H1 is so accurate by Levy and this
game is over over and Levy Rosman is our
first imcc finalist she's got a draw in
her pocket she's going to win this game
though she's going to go Rook F1 and the
position plays itself Paulina Shala she
moves on to the final she fought
valiantly she deserves her spot against
Gotham chess but look at this on E3
covering the checking Square Queen
D2 she now leads by three full points
yeah you can see her class Rook B5 is
begging to be played and boom it's on
the board she sacrificed the
rook and another Rook trade excellent he
is riled up oh my goodness little less
than 4 minutes left we are tied don't
pre-move no need to pre-move here oh my
goodness and Levy just notices and
Paulina sha leans back she BRS her hands
in the air like she just don't care she
has won the
[Music]
imcc
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
mus
[Music]
a
he
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
a
yeah
[Music]
a
I